Melani.
It's Melani but you can just say Mel.
Oh Mel.
Okay I got you.
She is playing Lifeline.
And then what's left?
I don't know.
Other than...
We got Watson and Bloodhound.
Yeah yeah yeah.
I can play Bloodhound.
Okay now I can do Watson.
That's not that important.
As long as you're playing up all those fences.
Yeah yeah as long as I'm fence bitch I'm fine.
I can do that.
Okay perfect.
Alright guys.
We're here!
I muted myself.
I need to get a shortcut for muting.
I learned on these tournaments these guys just talk to their chat.
They don't have actual...
Does that mean that I'm insane?
I need to get used to it because a lot of them they talk to their chat instead of talking to the team.
And I'm so not used to it.
I'm not used to that.
Bro they give the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Alright give me... there was no intro because we were talking about strats.
So I had to like figure something out.
I had to like let you guys in because we were talking about strats.
I wasn't even the latest person.
Look at team 11.
They're missing team 11 and team 9.
I'm not even the latest person.
How the fuck do you do shortcuts?
Oh keybinds.
What's a good button for key... guys.
What's a good button for... I don't even know what button to use to mute people.
Or like mute myself.
Oh my god how do you do this?
I tried to...
Where's the mute?
How do I fucking... oh toggle mute.
Control shift M.
Okay we are not doing that.
That's way too much.
Um...
What is a button that's not used too much?
Is 8 used for anything?
I don't know.
What do I...
Control shift... okay we're just gonna learn control shift M.
Yeah bro my ch...
Okay okay I'm looking at the discord channel.
And our entire channel...
Our entire channel of people is all muted.
Nobody wants to mute me.
Nobody wants to talk to anybody.
Everybody's muted.
Bro.
Oh my god everybody.
Oh my god.
Bro I'm looking...
I'm not gonna dox... obviously I'm not gonna dox the fucking discord names.
But like it's like mute mute mute mute mute mute mute mute.
Like every other channel.
Every channel is like mute mute mute.
And then one guy's not muted.
And then...
Timmy's channel they're all actually talking to each other.
Oh my god.
Timmy and Naughty and Reptar.
Like team 8, 7, and 5 are actually talking to each other.
That's crazy.
I think I cooked something up.
What's up?
What if we do...
What if we do Mel on Bang?
Doki you on...
You're still gonna be on Watson?
Sweet.
And then...
I can play Path.
Okay.
And then...
I just did the shortcut guys.
What else do we play?
I just did the fucking shortcut.
Do we still want Bloodhound or Sands?
Yeah like I'm like kinda thinking Bloodhound might not even be that worth it.
Yeah I mean if you smoke and I'm in my ult I can't see shit.
Yeah so like what as the fourth though?
Bang, Lifeline, Path.
All these strats.
Wait wait wait.
If you're gonna go to Newcastle, if you're gonna go...
If you're gonna get off Bang you should just play like Newcastle or Lifeline.
So Lifeline?
I don't know what...
I haven't touched Apex in a while guys.
Oh yeah then it would be you on Lifeline.
I'm just gonna exist.
I'm like...
I'm like thinking...
How the mighty have fallen.
Pathfinder might be pretty goaded for this.
So I fall...
There hasn't been like an engaging FPS games in so long.
And then no Sands.
I don't think Sands are gonna really be that important in like 4v4s.
Like we're gonna fucking know this.
I think we're gonna have a lot of people where people are.
You know?
Like it's literally...
It's like...
There's a lot of people.
Massive squads.
There's so many people.
There's 15 teams and there's 4 people for each team.
I think Sands will be that important.
Bring up the Discord.
Max out Melanie and bring up Bree.
OK.
Max out Melanie.
Bring up Bree.
Are you excited?
Sound guy to do sound check every two games?
I'm so excited.
All right.
Bringing it up right now.
Here we go.
All right.
I did it.
Anyway, so every two games, every two games, we are, we're going to swap teams.
It's gonna be randomized teams.
So, by the way, I participated, okay, this is on me.
I participated in a lot of Tempo's tournaments, but I haven't got paid for one of them because I've yet to do the tax forms.
I was like, wait, have I been paid yet?
Tempo's like, didn't do the tax forms.
I've been telling you to do the goddamn tax forms for months, Doki.
We can't pay you because you still haven't done the tax forms.
I was like, oh shit.
My bad.
But then like, a couple of months later, I'd just be like, hey, have I been paid yet?
And Tempo's just like, please, we sent you the tax forms.
So, anyway, I should get, I should do the tax forms soon.
I should do the tax forms for, for, it's because, okay, no, I do my taxes, but I can't receive any of my tournament winnings from Apex because I keep forgetting to do the main tax form to receive the tournament earnings.
I can't get tax evasions if I don't receive the money.
So, so I keep forgetting, I keep forgetting to do them.
And because of that, I have yet to be paid.
I've been doing this for like free so far.
That's like at least like, I swear, I think that's at least $10,000 that Tempo's been holding on to for me.
Oh my god, I'm a mess.
Tempo's literally holding 10k from me right now.
Just like 10k but mới 10k back in the day.
Okay,
step by step, guys.
We're slowly, very slowly fixing, fixing step.
Little, little...
Hey,
at least I'm not committing tax fraud.
I'm just not receiving the money.
I have an accountant.
I just...
The issue is that all I need to do is forward the form.
I'm making this more worse for me.
That is my only issue.
I just haven't forwarded the form to my accountant.
That... look.
That's a lot of buttons to press, guys.
That's a lot of buttons to press.
Chat.
So, it's not my fault.
It's just a lot.
That's a lot of buttons.
Please, we're worried.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Speaking of engaging FPS games, Valve just banned like a thousand of the cheaters and bots in TF2.
And the game is finally playable after years.
It's amazing.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I don't think there's a whole competitive scene for TF2 anymore.
You can say that it used to, but there's not really much of a competitive scene.
I think like... I don't know.
I'm down to come back to Apex again in the future.
It's just that it feels like... definitely... I was talking to Ditto and like we were like, you know, crying about the lack of engaging FPS... like new FPS games and stuff.
Ditto was like, oh, you should play the finals again.
Because apparently the finals got better.
But I feel like... yeah, it might be better.
But I feel like there's no competitive scene.
I just like games with a competitive scene because it just makes it much more... I guess like...
It just makes it much more... like there's like a worth to playing it.
I know there's like leaderboards, there's like top 500 for finals.
But... you can't really flex it.
If you tell somebody, I'm top 500 in the finals, they'll be like, what?
It's just... look, I need the ego boost.
Like, what's the point if I can't flex that shit, you know?
What's the point if I can be like, I'm top 500 in something and then they'll be like, what?
Esports seems to be dying in general.
It's dying because a lot of people... a lot of boosts.
Boomers who know nothing about esports are like funding a lot of money into the esports scene.
And then now they're pulling out because they realize like, wait, the investments were never worth it.
So because of that, a lot of the esports companies are dying now because they got a lot of boomers that were like, wow, let me commit $10 billion to the Overwatch League and buy a spot.
And like, what was it?
There was like football teams, like football owners that were like, Overwatch League.
It's going to be the next NFL.
Let me invest like $10 billion into getting a spot for Los Angeles.
And then... sorry, Los Angeles.
I don't know.
And now they're like pulling out the investment and they're now scared to invest in esports because they're just like, oh, wait, maybe that wasn't a good idea.
Now I'm never going to invest ever again because of that one time when I invested in this watch.
I invested in one thing and it wasn't worth it.
So that's why like, that's why esports is dying.
It's not because of like, oh, it's because like over the years, it's people were just like, no.
Also, like my chat's dead and I don't know how to fix it.
I don't know.
Oh, there you go.
I fixed it.
JK, I knew how to fix it.
It can be profitable.
You just can't.
Like, you just have to like invest smartly into things.
You can't just chuck a million dollars into something and then just be...
And then also there was never...
There's no like oversight.
That's...
This is oversight esports, by the way.
This tournament is like run by oversight.
But there's no like...
There's no...
What's the word?
There's no like anybody like actually like inspecting and like monitoring where the money is going to.
And...
Because like people would be like...
I'm going to chuck 20 billion into TSM.
And I want you to rename your org name to FTX.
Sorry.
It's not too soon.
He's in jail now.
And TSM, you can spend as much money as you want on anything you want with that 20 billion dollars.
And because of that, like they fucked up because...
Because like, you know, they didn't monitor where the money was spent and it was actually a scam in the end.
Yeah.
I'm ready.
I got the comp.
Yeah.
I got the juice.
Are you changing it?
Yeah, we're...
I got the juice.
We're saying everything the same, but I'm going to play Newcastle instead of Path.
Lifeline, Newcastle, Perth.
Wait, are they like contesting for stuff like...
Bri, Bri, Bri, you're going to play Lifeline.
You're going to play Lifeline.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Who the fuck is Watson?
Oh, there she is.
Guys, we have a problem.
I have to tab to my Discord to mute my Discord.
We have a problem.
All right.
We're landing at Rig and Basin.
I'll just like tell you guys where to land when we drop.
I don't think we're contested, so we shouldn't have to fight anyone.
Yay.
That's great to know.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, I think we're good.
Oh, my God.
It's King's Canyon, the smallest fucking map?
There's two on this first, yeah.
Oh, my God.
With four players per team.
Okay, this is...
This is going to be a massacre.
All right.
Um...
You want to go?
Mel, you're going to land towards Basin.
Here, drop us.
I'm going to go Basin with Mel and then someone land...
Someone land here.
Okay, I'll land over here.
And then someone land at the actual like Rig.
All right.
I'll land here then.
Okay.
Yay.
I'm going to go like far side of here.
Ooh.
Guys, I'm fucked.
This team doesn't talk.
Oh, my God.
Oh, let's hope they don't require me to communicate.
I'm fucked.
I don't...
I don't remember how to socialize.
It's okay.
I have no input.
I have no input to give to these people at the moment.
I literally just exist.
So, I'm going to...
It's okay guys.
We will tap back.
We will unmute.
How do you make friends again?
Oh my god I haven't done this in so long.
I'm so...
I'm so... shit I'm a mess.
I'm a fucking mess right now.
I don't know how to communicate with strangers.
I... guys I used to be so good at this.
I don't know.
I used to be so good at interacting with strangers.
Okay I actually don't need that.
I don't know what to run.
I don't even know what's good anymore.
I'm so...
Okay... I guess I'm heading over to...
Looking for a Havoc.
And also...
I need Hemlock.
Okay.
Havoc and Hemlock.
Ooh!
And...
Alright guys.
I'm gonna try it.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna interact.
Let's hope I don't get shot when I tap out.
Are we supposed to head to you, Dropped?
Yeah.
You guys can just like loot towards me.
Alright.
Cool.
You're gonna go hit that console.
Doki.
Where the fuck?
Oh.
Where am I?
Oh my god that's so far.
Okay.
Heading over.
Yeah you're good.
Doki can you carry the ultimate?
Or...
Yeah I can.
I have space.
Where is it?
I think that's...
Yeah yeah yeah.
Should I do the fast revive or the attack cooldown?
So I have my drone up then.
Do fast revive.
What about me?
Do I get revive or falling?
You do the Arc Star one.
Alright.
Here we go.
Ooh.
What do you think end zone's gonna be?
This will probably just end towards the map room.
So... Oh my god.
That's so far.
We're gonna like...
Kinda rotate.
Yeah.
Hmm.
Oh I think we're...
I'm thinking we go towards... I'm thinking we go towards labs.
We wanna get to purple.
So that way um...
We can get Brie her...
Gold res.
Wait.
A team died already?
How?
How did a team really die?
It was Hal's team.
Okay we're better than Hal.
No matter what.
We're better than Hal.
That's crazy.
Okay.
I'll carry.
Oh there's a hemlock.
Let's see.
Alright we have four evacs.
Alright.
That's fucking good.
Yeah.
We should um... look to get this evo harv and then hit this assault bin and then we should all be perp off of those too.
Yeah!
And then once we do that we can probably uh...
Hit the labs portal and like fly and take something.
Alright.
Raise that.
We hear nothing right now.
I hear shots on the right.
I hear shots on the west.
I think they're fighting over there on the west.
Oh wait I see I see there's a Bangalore ult.
And a Gibby ult.
Yeah.
Go get that assault bin Mel.
Are we gonna fight them or are we just gonna fly away?
Nah.
It's only placement so like...
Wait what placement do you get money?
I don't remember.
Top six.
Top six?
Okay.
That's easy.
Yeah I see that.
Set that assault bin.
We're gonna go to labs after that.
Nice.
Thank you.
Let me go ahead and drop my drop.
While we're over here.
Do I get split circuit or power pylon?
Double HP or two pylons?
Double HP yeah.
Double HP on that.
Nice.
You or me?
Me right?
Link.
Yeah I mean you just keep it on lifeline yeah?
Yep.
Alright let's go hit the portal here.
Yay.
I'm still holding that turbo for you.
Oh okay I can take it.
Oh there's somebody in map room.
They stuck their territory there.
Yeah.
Alright let's go hit the portal.
Wait where are we then?
Where are we planning on going anyway?
We're gonna fly towards Hydrodom.
Okay.
And then we're gonna like look to probably try and like maybe get on a wall here or something.
We're just looking to get into uh...
Repulsor.
Alright.
You ready?
Take it.
Wee!
Looking like...
Looks like the wall's gonna be free.
I think we land towards the left over here.
Okay.
And like over here and then I'm gonna evac all three of us up to the top.
I...
I fucked up my fall.
I forgot a dolphin.
You're good.
It's okay.
Let's hope nobody shoots the evac.
They are fighting in these buildings in front of us.
It's all crypto.
Really?
Okay.
Oh yeah.
I just heal on drone here actually.
Almost here guys.
Yep.
You're good.
Hey.
Hey!
We going in?
I think we just take our close building here.
Alright.
Climbing up.
They might be on the other side.
I think they are.
Oh.
Massacre.
You see this lifeline?
Do they see us?
Yep.
Nice.
Yay!
Watch out behind.
I'm dragging around.
Nice.
I got my drone for you too.
I'm gonna watch the other door.
Can you... The door's broken.
Can you put fences everywhere?
Yeah.
I forgot I was watching for a sec when you died.
You're so nice.
I was like, oh yeah.
Should we put pylon?
There's a sniper.
Probably put it in the room.
Yeah.
Put it in here.
You're all good on bats?
I have five bats.
Watch that sniper.
Just keep this door closed.
If you get shot or anything, you can just come and heal on this.
Whoa!
Yeah.
Melanie's gone, Bri.
How many more fence do I have?
A lot.
Here you go.
It's okay.
It's like a little puzzle.
What do I have?
Oh, I have two more.
Uhh...
Nice.
Oh, they have a fuckin' ramp right there.
It's okay.
Now we live.
We live here until we're top six.
We don't have to do anything.
Yeah, we're vibin'.
Woooo!
Guys, I haven't touched this game in two weeks.
I...
Oh!
Girl!
I just got my new PC.
No passion.
They smoked those.
Guys, this is not my main game, guys.
Yeah, if they pull this...
We just gotta fight out.
Can you come play out here with me, Mel?
Just smoke right here and cross.
I think if we get pushed, we need to play on this side.
By the way.
We'll get sniped on the other side.
Yeah, we gotta make sure...
If we get pushed, don't ever peek on the west side.
You'll get shot from the whole server.
Yeah.
Ooh, let's help zone.
Hands on us.
Yeah, I mean...
Honestly, if the zone...
Oh, what the fuck?
Hey, there's somebody right here.
Be careful.
They might be able to see you if you're in here.
Gotcha.
It's okay.
I don't need it.
I'm healing on the drone, by the way.
Should I drop my care pack in front of this other door?
Or in front of this back door?
Ooh, that zone shit.
Right here, so we can have a little bit more cover to peek out.
Alright, we're not safe.
Can we...
No!
Can we start moving this way?
Yeah.
Can you guys come out here?
Can you smoke out here?
Just, yeah, loot your pack.
Smoke out here.
Ooh.
Wait, which... where are we?
Are we using a redeploy or...
We're gonna like...
Yeah, we're gonna like... we're gonna like run out to our north.
Just come to me.
Just come to me and drop down.
Alright.
We're gonna like look to just get in zone, honestly.
Okay.
Here, let's go right together.
All together.
I feel so safe running in the open.
We're just gonna get... we're just gonna get in the bunker here in front of us.
Okay.
You guys ready to cross?
Maybe smoke right here, Mel?
Oh, jeez.
Cross here, cross here.
Run, they can't shoot down.
Okay, just play here for now.
Let's get like, just... we're gonna hold all this.
Okay.
I honestly want you guys to come all the way to me.
Come all the way to me.
Coming.
Come, come, come.
Alright.
We're gonna play...
somewhere here.
I don't think... nobody's in here.
Nobody's in there?
Would you rather play that building?
Honestly, yeah.
Okay, I'm gonna take my fences.
We can like just play kind of everything, you know?
Yeah, yeah.
We don't really want anyone to play near us.
Alright, fencing.
Should I put my ult somewhere here?
Yeah, you can put it like maybe right in the middle here.
Alright.
Just like right in the middle of those two things.
There's stuff here.
Okay, okay.
I can't put it here because there's stuff in front of us.
Please somebody...
take some of the things.
They popped the ziv.
I almost cracked this here.
They have purple.
They're getting shot right now.
Alright.
This is the best I can put my ult.
I might be able to nade one here.
I killed one.
Nice.
Ooh, nice kill.
They're looking down.
I wouldn't take that.
I'm vortnating.
Yeah, I didn't get hits.
I'll take that when I'm back.
I almost killed one.
They're both low up there.
I'm gonna bang ult them.
I think the bang died again.
If we get a bunch of ticks, I think we like...
I cracked them.
Shit on them.
Can we take it?
I'm going with you.
One down.
I got it all day.
I got the other teams.
I thirsted.
Nice.
I'm down here with you guys, so...
I'm gonna loot him.
I can give you an evac here.
I'm gonna loot this stuff.
He has bats.
I got six.
Alright, this is looking like an evac in angle.
Yeah.
Do we have a tower and try to play for Rook of Haste, do you think?
Do we reach all the way over there?
No, we don't.
It's not really possible.
Honestly, I think our play is to go like there.
What do I do?
Yeah, like just one.
You see this?
This is one guy.
You see that?
It's just one guy there.
I think what we're gonna do is two of us, at least two of us are gonna pop evacs.
Doki, we're gonna pop you an evac, so don't worry.
Oh yeah.
I have an evac too.
Yeah, we do.
Alright, here I'm gonna pop it.
Pop your evac up here, someone.
Woah, woah, woah.
You can't.
We're just gonna take this one then.
There's an evac on the right as well.
You guys ready?
We're going for that ping right there, okay?
Don't dip at all.
Just fly straight to it.
I'm gonna try and wall instantly, okay?
Okay.
Just land Doki and you're gonna need a gen here.
It's only two guys.
I got hit for 100.
I'm already dead.
I'm holding.
I'm dead.
You gotta tap me, tap me, tap me.
Fight, fight, fight.
It's only two guys.
Oh, I couldn't.
No!
Now we're getting shot in the ass.
Yeah, we got shot by everybody there.
That was so many people.
These guys are literally just holding everything, bro.
I know, there's nowhere to move into.
Oh my god.
That sucks.
Yeah, the end zone was pretty fucked.
I literally got hit in the air for 100.
Yeah, I did see that.
Oh, yeah.
You lost all your shield.
Yeah, I literally didn't even get to shoot him.
Man, that sucks.
Okay, we have a second game in KC.
Well, yeah, how does it work?
Is it randomized teams every game?
It's every two games.
Every map is a new team.
Oh, really?
Yeah.
Every map is a new?
Yeah, every map is a new team.
So, like, KC is a new team.
Like, KC, we stick together.
And then after KC, we dip.
Okay, okay.
Because it's every two games.
And then on the second game, Temple's gonna tell us.
Tell us, like, who our new teams are.
Okay, gotcha.
Alright.
It's okay.
We have round two!
We have round two of this team.
Now I need to look at fucking Sound Guy's notes on, like, how to adjust everybody.
Yes, there's, like, five frames because I'm tabbed out.
Alright.
Melanie is quiet.
Yeah.
She's so quiet right now.
Um...
It'll be time to switch though.
Honestly, I'm gonna let her be quiet.
Okay, so Sound Guy does not like Melanie.
Okay.
Sound Guy was just like, it's alright.
Because everybody else sounds okay apparently.
Just don't say it like that!
Alright.
Um, but everybody else sounds okay, right?
Sound Guy is just, fuck Melanie, right?
And people's chat was like, I wanna hear what Melanie has to say.
Like, I...
Um...
But yeah, Sound Guy is...
Is everybody else okay though?
Is every... everybody else okay?
Are we...
Are we good to go with everybody else?
Wow, Sound Guy.
How could you...
I just met Melanie.
I can't... and she's my new Apex Oshi.
Yeah, okay.
As long as...
I guess as long as it's dropped and free.
Sounds okay.
Um...
Yeah.
If I look left and right you can see... it's not noticeable.
Not noticeable because uh... uh...
Because like, um... I'm not like as big on the screen.
But I mean I could just... okay I'll show you guys.
I'll show you guys.
Okay.
Actually no because I can't... I don't have the...
I don't have the keyboard shortcut to like reposition myself and I'm lazy.
So look... zoom in on your...
Ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha!
Oh!
Nevermind.
Apparently... nevermind.
I disabled my hockey.
Give me a sec guys.
Let me fix this.
Okay.
I need to be... I need to disappear for a sec because like I have my bindings to like items that would put items out on my screen.
So that's why it doesn't work.
Give me a sec.
I disappear now.
So I have to disable some stuff.
I disabled my...
Alright here we go.
Okay.
Um...
I need to disable stuff and only put aimbot.
Ha ha ha ha!
Because...
Like I said...
If I... if I...
Turn it on... I would have...
So many things are gonna start fucking going yee-haw.
Ha ha ha ha!
A lot of things are just gonna suddenly show up and we'll be so confused.
Alright there we go.
Um... hockey's a bitch.
Okay.
Um...
Alright.
I'm back in it.
Alright so you see this?
Whoa!
So if I start aiming it'll be like...
Zoom.
And then... Okay because I can now... I'll show you guys.
Huge.
You see that?
Whoa whoa.
Whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa!
Left right left right whoa!
Left right left right!
Whoa!
Ha ha ha ha ha!
And then aim!
Whoa whoa whoa!
So yes.
That's how it works guys.
Ummm...
So yeah.
It's okay.
Now I won't like throw in like 20 different toggles in while I'm playing.
So...
At least like now we know like nobody's contesting us.
That's good to know.
Uh... I can see the code.
Guys see I told you even though I have aimbot eyes even though I have aimbot eyes it doesn't mean jack shit cause we didn't get... we didn't even get top 6.
So...
It's...
Ha ha ha ha ha!
So it doesn't matter.
You can't be like oh my god you have wallhacks.
Like that didn't do jack shit.
Wallhacks not gonna save me from 4 different peop- from 20 people shooting at me.
Like...
Ha ha ha ha ha!
For fuck- like 20 people were shooting at me.
You think wallhacks can save me?
I'll just get to see those 20 people uh...
Surrounding me.
Hmm... I don't have- I don't have the speed hacks.
That's why.
I can't go- I'm not Sonic.
Who won?
Saucer won?
Who's on his team?
And can he be on my team next game?
Ha ha ha ha!
Alright which team are we better than?
Where's us?
Dropped.
We're better- we're better than half of- oh wait!
He's not TSM anymore.
We're better- Ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha ha!
Forgot.
He's- he's- he's- Not in TSM but at least we're better than Falcon!
We're better than Falcon!
And TSM!
And half of TSM.
Ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha!
My- my- My benchmark is that as long as I'm better than Hal in a turni- like for a game in a tournament like that means I've made it.
That means like I'm not that bad.
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha ha!
That's all that matters.
As long as you're better than Hal, placed higher than Hal in any game, then you know, you know that you're not dogshit.
You're- Ha ha ha ha!
That's a win!
You placed higher than the CEO of Apex Legends?
That's a fucking win!
Ha ha ha ha!
Poor Hal.
He's- what is he gonna cry?
For his millions of dollars of playing for Saudi Arabia?
Like- Ha ha ha ha!
Like- Oh no!
Ha ha ha ha!
Doki, you can't- You can't say that!
Bro, he doesn't care?
He doesn't fucking care?
Ha ha ha!
Bro!
He has the oil money!
Like, what the fuck?
Do you think he really cares about getting an additional- Bro, how much do you win?
How much money do you win from this?
Per game?
Like two thou- Like, okay, 2,800 split by four.
Guys, 2,800 split by four, guys.
Um...
This next game...
We're gonna hit...
$700.
Do you think he cares about $700?
When he has literally oil money?
That way we can know where the game is gonna end, you know?
Okay, yeah, I'm down.
And then I'm gonna play Pathfinder so we can have UAVs.
Okay.
That way we can hit the third circle and then just...
basically also UAV to see what spots are open and then just rotate in.
Okay, gotcha.
A lot of people are playing Valk also.
Yeah, but I mean, we're finding so many EVACs, I don't think we need Valk.
I don't think we- Yeah, I think Valk is just for like, if none of them have EVACs type deal.
Yeah.
I don't know if it's just a bonus.
But we had four EVACs and three POIs.
Yeah, we're gonna get plenty of EVACs.
I was thinking about playing Valk too, but...
I think everything else is just better.
So only you're changing the character, right?
Yeah, yeah.
We're keeping the same characters other than me.
Okay.
Okay, who said that?
Well, we know you don't care now.
Look, I care!
I'm just lazy!
That's different!
I have a million things going on!
I care too!
I don't know what I'm talking about!
I also care!
I just have a million things!
I just do it right now.
Now I'm not gonna forfeit just to spite you.
Thank you.
And you're like, Toki, are you a child?
You know how people, kids are like, now that mom wants me to do it, I'm not gonna do it.
I'm gonna hold that 10k hostage.
That's gonna be like my rainy day fund.
The moment I'm like, the moment I'm like, oh shit, I need 10k to pay off something, I'll do the tax for it.
I'm gonna make Tempo hold on to the money and have it build up more and more and more.
Until I...
It's like interest rates, except there's no interest rate going in.
It's like he's holding it in just for the sake of holding it in.
He's my Tempo bank.
Tempo's gonna be my bank.
My bank account.
My emergency 10k whenever I need it.
It's not tax evasion if I don't do the forms!
It's not...
How am I evading taxes if I've never done the form?
I'm just not fucking claiming the money yet.
I just haven't...
Okay, you know what's funny?
So you know how I did that Apex sponsor?
Tempo's also handling that, too.
So...
Like, handling the payment for me.
So I still haven't...
I didn't...
So the tax form covers everything.
The tax form covers all the Apex payments.
I did the other tax forms!
Okay?
I did the high end tax forms!
I did so many!
Okay, I didn't.
My accountant did all the tax forms.
Okay, alright.
Tonight, tonight, after this, after this, in between...
In between this stream and Apcon stuff, I will forward my tax form over to my accountant.
And then I'll finally, I'll finally, I'll finally do the taxes.
I'll finally, I'll finally claim the taxes.
Not claim the taxes.
I'll finally claim my prize money.
My, I think, I think it's like at least 10k including the sponsor.
I got like, including the Apex sponsor money.
Um, I think it's 10k because I did so many fucking, um, I did so many like tournaments for Tempo.
So, um...
There's so many tax forms!
You don't understand!
There's so many forms!
I get sent so many forms!
I look at, I don't have to do any of them.
I just look at it.
And even then I'm like, there's so many forms!
And then...
This is gonna turn into the PC unboxing stream again.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
This is different, guys.
This is so different.
Oh my god.
It's not evading!
I just didn't, never claimed the money.
If I never, it's like I just did it for free.
Alright, round two.
Yeah!
This game is a W.
Yeah, top six!
No, we gotta have low expectations so it'll be a little surprise.
It's like a little birthday present.
Okay, okay.
I'm saying W though.
If you want top six, you're gonna want top six.
Top six!
What do you even get for top six?
Oh my god, yeah, $100.
Yeah, $100 each.
Oh my god, I can...
I can pay for my Disney Plus subscription with that.
What the fuck?
How much is that Disney Plus subscription?
I don't know, it's fucking Disney.
They always need more money.
I don't know, what do I get to with my $100?
That I'm gonna add to the temple bank.
One whole month.
Yes.
Guys, that's $100 to the temple bank!
For after I fucking death you, my gun would not survive.
Yeah, I mean honestly I fucking...
And I tried to tap whoever went down after that too, and I was like, ugh.
I'm just rusty on Newcastle, I could've lived there.
Ditto for life.
If I would've just Q'd, if I would've just thrown my Q, my shield, I could've probably lived, but I just fucking haven't played the trick card yet.
The temple bank.
You guys invest in the Doki bank, I keep my money in the temple bank.
Alright, I need to head over to the center.
You hear Doki?
Yeah, I'm not unmuted, no!
You can land over here, Mel.
Maybe I should do push to talk.
Like loot under the balloon and stuff.
Push to talk seems so much more convenient now.
Now that I think about it.
In these games.
Oh my god.
Why did I do push to talk?
I should've just been doing push to talk!
Alright.
Push to talk is... guys, it's been a while.
Guys, I... doing these tournaments.
I feel like I just... I'm off my groove.
I'm off my groove with like socializing with new people.
It's just... it's been... it's been rough.
I used all of it at Avcon.
No, they can't... I muted myself.
That's why they're like, are you alive?
And I'm like, oh no, I'm still muted.
I just wanted to talk to you guys.
No, I won't forget.
I think I did... did I do push to talk before?
Guys, it's... bro, I don't remember.
It's been so long since I played with a randomized team.
Oh my god.
They don't need to hear me.
I give no actual input.
Make sure you guys ping Evax for each other if you see him.
Yep, gotcha.
Like, I... my... my intel is literally useless to them.
They don't need my intel.
Like, how am I gonna help my team anyway?
I'm not gonna assist them in any way.
Ooh.
Okay.
Oh, falling stars.
Nice.
Alright.
Excellent.
I mean, it's not like... okay, yes, I am an introvert.
It's just that... like...
I got an Evax.
Okay, also, there's four of us, which means that's close.
Looking for a Havoc?
Four of us equals getting hit by Introvert Doki because there's four of us now.
It's easier when there's three!
When it's three, it's so much easier.
You didn't gaslight?
I think they really want that thousand dollars.
Or no, seven hundred dollars.
Here's an Evax, Mel.
I feel like they really want that seven.
Like, I can tell they're also like super...
This is a try-hard squad.
These guys care.
These guys actually care.
I'm good.
I got size.
I'm chillin'.
Yeah, I need a...
Alright.
I'm gonna loot this and then...
Oh my god, no heavy ammo.
I'm gonna loot this and I'm gonna mute myself, guys.
I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna do it, guys.
I'm gonna hit this UAV.
Oh god, I didn't do the control.
I didn't do my job.
Doki, just run over here and hit your console when you can.
Oh my god, I knew I didn't do it.
I didn't do my job.
I'm so sorry.
Oh my god, here we go.
And then we're just gonna go towards this UAV next.
Alright.
Nice.
I want money to give to them.
I want money to put in my tempo bank.
Alright, guys.
This is the last thing I'll say.
I'll see you guys on the other side before I try to talk to my team and socialize.
I was gonna be going towards...
Oh my god, we're so far from zone again.
No.
Yeah, yeah.
We're good though.
Hit that assault bin, Mel.
I'm going to...
I need a hemlock if you'll find one.
Alright.
Oh, I want that bat.
I still have...
I still have a white backpack so if anybody finds a blue...
Can you smoke me on this beacon, Mel?
Just come up, like climb up.
I'll wait for you.
Yeah, there is a team in your base so I'm gonna go body block.
Yay!
Yeah, there's a lot.
Okay.
Hit this.
Um...
This is just kind of a hard zone to read, honestly.
Like, I want us to play for that but it's gonna be pretty impossible to do that.
Yeah.
I mean, we have four evacs again.
I'm thinking like...
We can go for like this house maybe?
Are you getting this harvester?
For now.
Yeah.
Hold up where?
On the top spot?
Yeah, I mean...
Yeah.
We can like hold all that.
Mm-hmm.
I don't have any...
There was like...
There was like a bunch of people like...
In front of us.
Yeah.
There's somebody there.
Evac in front of us.
We can maybe shoot one of these guys off of this.
Last one.
Oh, nobody's getting on.
They're not taking it.
They're in front of us.
They're in front of us in the open here.
They know about us.
They have blues.
Cracked one.
They're sliding down the hill.
Lobo's cracked.
Lobo's cracked flush.
Oh, nice.
Nice.
Can you guys full?
Shoot him.
Right here.
No, he's sliding down the hill.
Yeah, they ulted.
They ulted.
They did.
They did slide him.
Okay.
I'm getting a right angle.
Can someone look at our back as well?
I'm looking.
I lost our back.
Oh.
I'll look at them.
I'm just getting sent all...
You're getting sniped from across the way.
I'm good.
I'm looking behind us.
Nothing behind us yet.
I think they got the rez up.
Can we just go through the choke?
Okay.
Yeah.
I just don't really know where the full kill's at or anything.
No.
Am I kidding?
I'm pretty sure they rez'd it.
Probably.
Yeah.
Because they ulted us off.
There's a team here.
Chill.
I'm gonna pop us a zip.
Okay.
Don't be dropped.
I'm good.
Just back up.
Back up through zone here.
We're safe like right here on this corner.
Okay.
There's a lot of teams here.
We might want to just wrap around a cage.
We can still redeploy.
Can we?
Yeah.
But these guys might shoot us.
So we should just run off.
I'm done.
We can come around here and honestly play for these beacons.
Okay.
I need to drop my pack too for my gold.
We got a team coming.
There might be a team coming.
Wasn't a team on this side?
Because they came from...
There was.
Yeah.
We can check it.
You can pop your pack here.
Do we have heal drone or no?
I think they're gone.
Yeah.
They're gone.
Alright.
Come in the zone with me Doki.
You're gonna hit the console.
Okay.
I got drone.
I'm gonna hit the UAV.
Yeah.
We can get drone when you get out Doki.
You can just pop ranges.
Hey.
What else did they got?
Yeah.
I'll give it to Marge.
Okay.
See.
Their melor dropped.
Yeah.
I'll come back and get it.
I'm just...
Okay.
I'm gonna hit these beacons real quick.
Yep.
Okay.
I'm just gonna syringe before I take this.
Yep.
You're gonna be good.
It's only zone one.
Yeah.
It's not that far.
Uh... yeah.
Okay.
Yeah.
This...
Okay.
Yes!
That's free.
Oh god, if I'm gonna make it...
You can just pop a wrench or something, pop a heal.
Yeah, I'm not gonna make it.
It'll be good.
Alright.
Yeah, look at Bunker by the way.
Like Bunker's free.
We could literally just evac there, couldn't we?
Like from this hill?
I think we could make it in the doorway.
Does anyone have extra syringes?
Please.
Come to us Mel.
I'm gonna get the Harvester then.
I don't think it's really that worth it.
You're gonna get shot from everyone.
Just come to us.
We should go for a spot here.
I'm heading over.
I'm gonna wait for Mel to pop a bat and everything.
Can you drop me drone?
I got 12 seconds.
I just dropped it for her.
Alright.
We're going for Bunker door, okay?
Yep.
If Bunker door is taken, we're going to swerve back.
It looks free though.
I don't see any movement there.
If there's a team here, we just gotta slam it, okay?
You need to smoke the door here.
There's a team here.
Play it, pop, play it, pop.
Oh no.
I need to get up top.
They're setting up in there though.
I might have to smoke for me again so I can get up there.
Oh god.
I think another team is walking up there.
I live here now.
There's kids up top looking at y'all.
I need to get over there to y'all.
Goodbye.
I hope the team doesn't see me over here.
Oh god.
I know you're good.
If the team up top doesn't see me, I'll be fine.
I don't have an ult, Excel.
So, yeah.
That's crazy.
I literally said to land up here.
They might be swinging out on you.
I almost cracked.
I almost killed the bang.
I can't see anything.
I'm just getting sniped from the side.
The other team is just gonna look at me over here.
That's not good.
They're just looking at me over here though.
I'm gonna try to stay right here.
Oh no.
Hello.
I'm gonna...
Oh, you have an ult, Excel.
Nice.
One of us will live.
Are you actually getting me?
I am.
They're gonna shoot at me, fuck off!
I don't know if this will help you.
Oh, hey!
They want me so bad.
Are you safe to sit here?
I don't think so.
But where else are we gonna go?
Nah, nowhere.
It's okay!
Look at all these Arc-Stars that they threw at us!
You get them when they...
Oh, I did not know that.
Oh God!
Okay!
Okay.
Whoa, okay.
Alright, chill a little bit.
Okay.
That's alright.
You were safe up there still?
If you can get your gen back, you could definitely like maybe gen behind there.
Yeah, yeah.
There might be enough space and then you guys can just play there.
I'm 38 at the moment, so it's gonna be a while.
Maybe check for ulti-excells on our box?
No, I took that ulti-excell.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
I would say wait till you're next gen and then yeah, just try to...
People up top are gonna be sliding down on us.
Yeah, pop your lifeline pack in front of you guys right there.
Because if you get a mobi, you could rez this.
That's true.
Try and get it as close as you can to you.
Yeah, I know.
That's what I'm trying to do.
So like look up.
There's a rock above you.
I see them.
I see them on the other side of that smoke.
Okay.
Maybe move out a little bit now, Bree, and like go to the right side and not that way.
Behind us?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Right there.
Perfect.
I just need to keep a good mobi.
Yeah, that's perfect.
It should give you a mobi.
It gives you like loot based on shit.
It should, yeah.
Oh.
Other side?
No, that's so fucking stupid.
No way.
Oh, was that your gold pack?
No, I already did my gold pack.
What RNG, guys?
I just gave another gold.
There was a supply.
That's so weird.
What?
I got scuffed as fuck.
It's okay.
We're not the team that died last.
75, guys.
The team died before us.
The team inside moved out?
I have no idea.
Right?
I'm just surviving.
I'm just worried about the team behind us up top.
No, I hear people in there.
They didn't move out.
Just be careful.
Because this might be a different team.
They might not know we're here.
Yeah.
This thing will... we left... I mean, I guess the only thing we can do is just Hail Mary redeploy.
We both have a redeploy.
That's behind us.
No, that wasn't... that was a bunker.
That was a bunker.
They're trying to kill you guys now.
Oh.
Climb up, maybe.
They don't.
Go climb up.
Please don't kill me climbing up.
Nope.
Yep.
It's not gonna fucking happen.
Goodbye.
Nice try, guys.
Thanks.
Holy shit.
There's so many people.
Yeah, I knew they were gonna try to ape us.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
Not last.
Second last.
Alright, GG's.
GG's, guys.
GG's.
Alright.
Oh my god, they all just left.
All alone in Team 2.
We're in the sense of camaraderie.
They all just left.
Who's my next team?
I'm with...
Shit, I am with Saucer!
Guys, remember?
Saucer got first!
I was like, oh my god, give me Saucer so I can also get first.
Oh my god, they heard.
Before Saucer leads us to our deaths.
They're all...
Guys, I don't know about you, but I died last.
I did my job.
I guess I'll also lead.
Alright, let's figure out how to do push to talk.
I haven't done push to talk in a long time.
Push to talk, okay.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
We'll do...
We'll do this.
Okay, mouse 3, yeah.
Alright.
Alright, we're push to talk now.
Everything's fine now.
We're push to talk now.
Alright, so our team...
Our second game...
Our third game, sorry.
The second game went by so fast.
Our third game is with...
Uhhhh...
Zero loves giving.
Faye.
And then there's me.
Then there's me.
So we have Saucer.
Uhhhh...
Zero and Faye.
Um...
Temple Bank is fixed, bro.
What if we like die so fast?
I can't believe, like...
Our pro died first.
How?
Like, literally all we need is our pro player to be alive.
To do something to like help me.
No, not...
Not Falcon Zero.
Content creator Falcon.
No, sorry.
Content creator Zero.
I have no idea who the Zero is.
But this is content creator Zero.
Um...
I mean, I live.
I lived.
I don't know.
As the weakest player...
I'm alive.
I...
I did my job.
And that was to survive.
Okay.
My job was literally survive.
And I did it.
Um...
There was no way we're gonna beat the bunker team.
Because the bunker literally was ramparted up.
Oh my gosh.
This...
This Bangalore is very confident.
Okay.
There's a reason why he's very confident.
This is...
This has to be their pro player.
This has...
You know what?
Oh, it's Zainu.
Yeah, he deserves to be conf...
Yeah.
I was like...
I was like, damn.
This is some fucking confident...
Uh...
Pro right there.
There's a reason why.
Fucking...
Roller brain right there.
I think that's why I haven't been playing Apex this much.
Because like...
Um...
I'm just...
I'm...
I just don't want to 1v1 controller players.
I'm just tired.
It's like...
It makes me...
Makes me wish I was adding Mrs. right now.
Yeah.
Zainu from SSG.
Um...
Uh...
Yeah.
I think that...
That's also why I haven't been playing a lot of Apex.
Because like...
I'm just tired.
Of 1v1'ing roller players.
Because it's just not as fun.
I think it...
It's just not as fun as 1v1'ing an MNK player.
Because you get to live a little longer.
You gotta live a little longer against MNK players.
So like...
You can see...
You can see if you'll die.
You know?
You can...
You can like...
Think a little bit longer.
Um...
I think that's why...
Like Ditto's been playing finals too.
Because...
She said like...
In the finals...
No one...
Uh...
People...
You can't really play...
What the f*** is that movement?
Goodbye Verhos.
Um...
Holy sh**.
That movement...
Was that Verhos that died?
I don't know.
But that...
Movement was not gonna...
F***ing...
That super glide is not gonna save you from Apex.
I just...
Poor guy.
Wait.
That Bangalore literally got top five for them.
He's gonna get hundred dollars.
Bro!
He got hundred dollars.
He can...
He can also...
Get Disney Plus subscription.
Go him!
Oh my god!
What the f*** in my...
Okay.
What is this game?
What the f- He's just creeping!
He's literally just creeping!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, he gets to watch that shitty Star Wars adaptation.
Guys, no one's playing Watson.
Watson, guys.
I don't think Apex was meant to be a 4v4 game.
Guys, I think there's a reason why Apex Legends was- figured out 3 was the magic number.
They realized 3 was the magic number for Apex Legends.
Bro, 4 is just too many.
4 is actually just too many.
Especially when it's like final zone.
You kinda like 4.
Yeah, but when you're like playing against a lot of really, really good players in teams of 4, it's...
It's a lie.
Oh shit.
It's okay.
We're not last.
As long as we're not last, that's all I care about too.
Wait, who's- who's AWOL?
Oh, that team.
Okay.
Alright, who's my next map?
This would- Saucer, 0, Faye, and me!
Alright.
Let's see.
What number is this?
Team 9.
Are there any new people in team 9?
Or...
No.
Okay, his old team is still in there, guys.
His old team is still in- I don't want to interrupt anybody.
His old team is still there.
Um...
Oh, I have to do team- I need to change it too.
Oh, that's so annoying.
Alright, let me...
fix this.
Uh... that's so annoying.
You gotta like change the avatars and everything too.
I need to...
I need to change it.
Alright.
Nobody's talking.
I don't want to be the first one to talk.
Really?
Someone... say anything!
Oh my god, she breathed!
Hello, hello.
Oh, thank god!
Hello!
Alright.
Hello, hello.
How were you guys' games?
Uh, it was good.
We came in sixth last game.
I was not last.
That's all that matters.
Exactly.
I got gas money.
Didn't win money, but I was not last.
You'll win some this game.
I promise.
Can't wait to win my hundred dollars.
I think I'll make more just streaming right now.
Chat!
I'll make more!
Not gonna lie, I think I'll make more just getting super chats at the moment.
Where's team nine?
Wait, I can't even join team nine.
Wait, alright.
So what are we playing?
Wait, Zazie, you got first.
It is what I'm about to say.
You have the game winning strat.
You know the meta.
Okay, Saucer is not existing.
Okay, nevermind.
Saucer's not here to help us.
Saucer's not here right now.
Would you please leave a message after the beep?
Akron!
Alright.
Alright, what's the comp?
What do you like?
My chat tells me it wins.
Lifeline good.
Pathfinder good.
I'll play Bang because I'm a one trick.
And then...
It's the fourth character.
Anything else?
But you won first!
What was the comp for first?
It was Newcastle, Rampart, Lifeline, Bang.
But I think Pathie instead of Newcastle is good.
Okay.
You guys okay if I take Pathie?
Alright.
Yeah, I cannot play him for the life of me so that is all you can do.
Okay.
Wait, what was it?
It was a Newcastle, Bang, and what?
Lifeline and...
Oh.
So...
Well, we're gonna do Path, Bang, Lifeline, Rampart probably.
Okay.
Actually, what map is this?
Olympus?
Okay.
I can do Lifeline.
Alright.
Can I go...
How much time do you think we got?
Let me in team 9!
Before the game starts.
Probably a good minute.
Couple minutes probably.
Okay.
You said we're doing Rampart.
Not last month!
Uh, yeah.
Turn down zero and bring up Saucy.
Alright.
Rampart's pretty good on this map.
Turn down zero.
Bring up... alright, I brought...
Can you give me a second?
I'm gonna see if my dog poops.
I'll be right back.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh my god, Push to Talk is so much better.
We got Hydroponics and Elysium.
Ooh, nice.
Yeah.
Okay.
And I'll bring the...
We'll just stand wherever Ring Console is if we get one.
Yep.
Alright.
Nice.
Oh, thank you guys!
Thank you for the extra...
Thank you.
We don't have to give more money to Tempo's bank account.
I'm just gonna...
Thank you guys for the superchats.
Avi, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you.
Yeah, probably.
DJ, thank you for the superchat.
Thank you.
Not last.
Money.
Thank god!
Not last!
That's all that matters.
You're beat to hell.
Oh, thank god, guys.
Thank god we don't have to give more money to Tempo's bank account.
I need a tempos bank.
Guys, I can't even get into my own team!
Because there's two... Team 9 isn't moving!
Let me in Team 9!
I practically got sixth place via Super Chat money.
Bro, I got... Oh my god!
Not only did I get sixth place, I got two sixth places.
Oh my god!
Somebody... Someone let me in Team 9.
Sad.
Please.
I'm gonna steal Verhulst's team.
Oh, thank god.
That's all you had to do!
Just...
Just sad face Team 9!
That's all you have to fucking do.
Sad face.
And then they'll be like...
Good.
I'm so sad.
I feel bad.
Alright, we have...
We have...
We have four more games left.
So we have...
I think... I don't know what our second...
Our third map is.
What is our third map?
Our third map is...
Broken Moon.
Alright, nice.
Broken Moon time.
I don't wanna get back into Apex though.
I just feel like...
It's definitely...
Definitely feels a little...
I think the content just feels a little dry at the moment.
It's more so of like...
I think it's not more so of like...
The game gunplay...
At the moment for Apex.
It's who you're playing with.
And also tournaments.
I think that's like basically...
At the moment... I think like...
Apex is at a place right now...
Where...
It's who you're playing with.
And also tournaments.
I feel like regular Apex...
And new season launches.
If there's new content.
This is why I didn't look into like the rank split.
I usually...
Just like if you're ever in a bangle, you could just slam the walls down.
In a triangle.
And you'll be safe.
Or like if there's a lot of nades.
I'm listening to my IGL.
Even though it doesn't matter to me.
I think like right now...
I've only been...
Um...
I've only been paying attention to...
Who you're playing with.
Tournaments.
And just new season stuff.
I heard the new season is going to be exciting.
I'm not going to spoil anything.
I'm going to make sure I don't leak anything.
But I heard that the new season might be pretty interesting.
So...
Can't wait to check out the new season.
Okay, I maxed out Saucer.
He's at 200 now.
He was at 160.
I'm actually surprised.
ShibuyaHal.
Decided to host V-Psycho for Apex again.
Because...
He said the last V-Psycho was the last one.
But it's never the last one.
I guess.
I'm just surprised.
I thought maybe...
I honestly thought the next V-Psycho would be a fighting game.
Centric one.
No.
We're just waiting for the game to start.
We're waiting for you!
You're stalling the game!
Wait, it was me?
Yeah, you're literally the last person!
Oh, shit.
There we go.
Honestly, I wouldn't be surprised if it was like...
Because they have...
ShibuyaHal has like merch sold.
Like actual merch sold in Japan.
And stuff like regarding V-Psycho.
There was literally like a little gang violence outside between...
What?
Oh, okay.
I was like...
I thought you meant like actual gang violence.
As in people were shooting.
I was like, do you live in America?
Yes.
Well, I do.
I came outside and there was a lady that had a corgi.
It was like a black and white corgi.
And I have a Yorkie.
And she's very territorial.
And she's not trained around dogs.
So the lady came up to me and she was like...
Is it okay?
I'm like, I'm not gonna say no!
And she was like, I don't know.
And then they kind of like smelled each other's nose.
I was like, aww.
And as they're connecting...
This damn rock wall that comes out of nowhere.
And...
Wait, where the fuck did the wrong one come from?
The third party!
I don't know.
He came out of nowhere and he started...
barking and pulling his owner hard.
And my dog got scared.
And that lady's dog got scared.
And the friendship kind of like separated.
And I was like, fuck!
This is the perfect connection!
So, K, did you get her number?
No.
Did you not get the old lady's number?
She'll understand!
The old lady's like...
You're not into gills.
She'll understand.
Fuck!
No!
But you don't care.
You don't care about your dog.
I care about my dog.
You'd rather your dog be a loner forever.
She has two people!
People are dogs!
That's different!
She's about to get a companion.
I'm about to get a cat also.
Cats are not dogs!
They want dog friends!
What if your only friend was a dog?
I mean, isn't that how it is?
Oh, you have no friends?
Right?
Man's best friend is a dog.
You're not even friends with your girlfriend?
But we were talking about the dog.
Why we went backwards?
You said, what if I was the only friend to the dog?
It's like saying, would you just want one friend that's not even a human?
I mean, personally, with issues that humans have, yes, I'd be okay with having a dog as a friend.
So, like, not even a girl.
Like, you don't even want your girlfriend to be your friend.
I do, I do, but excluding her because automatically she's my friend that's my girl.
So she's my girlfriend.
Yeah, but your dog doesn't even have like a girlfriend!
Like a girlfriend or a boyfriend.
Well, because she doesn't want nobody to come around her.
You don't know that!
We do know that!
What if she wants...
What if she wants a boyfriend?
What if she wants babies?
She can't have any.
Yeah, because you took away her choice.
I didn't.
I wasn't the one.
Make sure you take the UAB card.
I got you.
The one for people or the one for circle?
People, people.
That's the one I always got.
I got you.
Go Elysium with me, Zero.
And then Faye and Doki, you guys go Hydra.
Alright.
Perfect.
Cool.
I'm down with it.
I'll land southside, you go northside, Elysium.
Please!
I just hope we're not contested.
I'm gonna land on this side.
You have a spy banner here.
Alright, yeah, I'll land on that far left then.
I feel attacked.
That was so good.
You're attacked!
You poor dog!
Wait, why am I jump faster?
Shit, okay.
I didn't even realize.
Hey.
Sorry, I got so absorbed over the fucking die conversation.
I didn't even realize I was jump faster.
Can you sound my forehead?
Sure.
Alright, appreciate that.
I'm gonna go back.
It's okay.
We already bonded.
This team doesn't care as much.
We're running what we're looking for.
Snipers are good.
Alright, we're missing.
We're missing.
AR one trip.
I'm lost.
Sorry for your loss.
Alright.
Oh my god.
We're finally within zone.
Thank fucking god.
I feel like we didn't get zone.
I think another issue is we didn't get fucking zone.
It's okay guys.
Dad's also neutered.
There's an evac here.
I hate you.
Nice little oasis there.
I like it.
Shit.
Are you gonna take that?
You got that cash?
So...
Yeah.
Alright.
Yeah, I took away dad's choice too.
I thought you were calling UAV.
People call it man scan and all that weird shit.
I mean, it's just a UAV to me.
Do we want cooldown or rapid response?
The faster res.
Alright.
Alright, here you guys go.
So we got a team here.
And really nobody around us.
Holy shit.
It's okay.
He got neutered when he was super young.
So he didn't realize what he's lost.
Or any energy attachments.
I'm gonna grab nemesis.
I know like Havoc's better.
There's actually one on me.
He didn't know what he's lost if he got neutered as a child.
Alright, I'll just put a zipline there.
I'm gonna hold this turbo.
Wasn't there a Havoc somewhere?
Okay, not child child.
I did the recommended doctor suggestion.
The doctor suggested a recommended amount and I did that.
Do you want me to hit this UAV again?
Yes.
Gotcha.
Alright.
Let's check out that area.
Let's start working our way into Oasis.
Wait, where's the SNT?
There's a team coming.
Yeah, we're fine.
I see where you guys pinged the SNT.
There is one over here.
Where are we supposed to go?
Towards Oasis.
Like on the left side.
Does anyone need bats?
I have six.
I have one.
Are you guys good?
Yeah, we're good.
Where do you want to go?
Keep going left side over here.
I'm a refrigerator.
I don't want to get shot.
Alright.
Guys, I need to rebuy my push to talk.
My push to talk is melee.
I don't know if you guys noticed that.
Every time I'm melee, I'm pushing the talk.
I also need shield cells.
I couldn't find any.
I got four right here.
Alright, thank you.
Right next to the company.
Oh, we're good.
Are they right here?
Yeah.
I'm going to try to get over there.
Oh my god.
I poofed on them.
I have no science.
Can we evac once over here and go to Oasis?
Yeah, I'm dropping the evac.
Alright.
Team flying to Oasis.
Yeah.
There's a team pushing that already.
Oh, that's not great.
Can we go longer?
Right there.
I'm right there on my ping.
You guys can make it.
I'm going to smoke off the left and we drop down on the right and take the zip.
Okay.
Ah, bitch.
Just go right.
I'm the last person.
There's a guy under here.
One guy is alone.
You kill him.
I missed everything.
Set up on both sides.
Make sure we don't get pushed.
I'm going to just lurk around and see if we can get any picks.
Is that a sniper scope?
I'm coming right back.
It is.
I'm bringing up a site for you guys.
Sir.
If anybody needs it.
Appreciate it.
What would you prefer?
Bruiser or 2-4?
Bruiser.
Alright, Merry Christmas.
Thank you.
No problem.
Hey, a team died already.
Not last.
Yay!
So sorry.
I think I know the circle.
I think it's the circle that's here.
On this wall.
The circle that's over here.
Okay.
Or it might be the circle that's in this area.
Yeah, we can't really take the zips unless we get lucky and 3P a fight.
So we're going to play up into these stairs eventually.
Perfect.
Hi.
Oh, there's a team here.
I hear a lot of fights.
I'm going to go in the back.
I'm waiting around this wall.
Yeah.
This team is getting fought above us somewhere.
I'm looking to our left.
Alright, I'm going to charge my sentry up.
See if I can get a knucklehead in the head.
Guys.
I should not have made melee push to talk.
I didn't see anything about you.
Not really.
That was a very bad decision on my end.
Me too.
Oh, okay.
Oh shit.
I'm going back down.
Whoa.
I'm going to watch the bottom.
90.
Please don't fall from that.
I thought about it.
That's why I stopped so quick.
I'm scared.
Every time I push to talk, I melee and it pushes me forward.
Hahaha.
Oh my god.
What if I accidentally fall?
Probably unbind that.
Yeah.
I chose the wrong bindings.
You got a foot pedal?
No, what the fuck?
Last time I played Apex was two weeks ago.
Hahaha.
You should get one.
It's like two bucks on Amazon.
I am lagging really badly.
Uh oh.
I have 50k of loss.
Oh no.
How are you lagging?
It's going down.
We're good.
Nice.
You got anybody in the house on the internet?
Are you playing wifi?
No, I'm hardware.
I mean my boyfriend is overwatching.
Oh my god.
Tell him to fucking uninstall right now.
Exactly.
What the fuck is he doing?
That's not even worth playing right now.
At least he's playing rank, right?
What's his rank?
That means he's not even good if you don't even know his rank.
Damn.
If you knew his rank, you'd be proud of it.
You know.
I don't know what it is.
Yeah, yeah.
Damn.
Even my girlfriend knows my rank.
Hahaha.
I have a bad girlfriend.
It's okay.
I'll admit it.
No, no, no.
It's okay.
Oh shit.
I have a bad girlfriend.
Hahaha.
Can we get a switch on teams, please?
Damn.
Doesn't even know.
Hahaha.
That poor guy.
That poor guy worked so hard.
Hahaha.
He thought his girlfriend was proud of him.
But she doesn't even know he exists.
Hahaha.
I'll make an involved.
Should I anchor or come with you guys?
Anchor for now.
They're like fighting above.
They're like on roof.
Yeah.
Yeah, come to me.
Should I come over?
Yeah.
I hear people behind me.
They're peaking over.
Oh my God.
No.
Guys, I don't think that was smart gas.
Oh my god, there were so many teams!
Yeah, I think we should have held that.
I think we should have stayed, yeah.
Because look at the circle now.
We would have been comfortable for like two more circles.
Oh my god, we were!
Yeah, I was right about that circle.
It ends like... it's gonna end in that corner.
That top left corner, that top bottom corner.
I mean, placements matter more than kills.
Yeah.
Because that's when you get your $100.
It's okay, I can finally rebind my stuff.
Alright, I'll be back.
Alright, time to rebind.
Give me a sec, guys.
Alright, instead of melee, I'm gonna put it on a different binding.
Oh my god.
This is...
How do people do this?
How do Overwatch players...
No, sorry, not Overwatch.
How do Apex players do this?
Okay.
Alright, now it's my weapon swap.
Now it's better.
Now it's not...
Now I don't... it's not when I'm meleeing.
At least it's not...
I don't wanna get a foot pedal.
Foot pedal, you still have to bind it on something.
Don't you?
The foot pedal isn't like... a whole new bind.
It's not a whole new fucking bind though.
It's a weapon swap, so like...
I... oh wait, that could be worse, you're right.
Fuck, what do people use?
Control?
But like, then I'll be crouching while I'm talking!
Like...
Caps lock!
Wait, you're so right!
I'm gonna do caps lock, okay.
Alright.
I'm gonna rebind it on caps lock.
I'm so not... cause I'm usually used to using mouse... mouse bindings.
Um... mouse bindings for it.
And like, my mouse bindings are binded to stuff already.
So, that's why like...
Cause I use like push to talk for like...
Mouse 3 or mouse 4.
So it's like... I'm so not used to binding it outside of it.
Um...
Okay, caps lock.
Alright.
Nothing can go wrong with caps lock, guys.
Nothing can go wrong with caps lock.
Look...
Our... our pro players through...
We literally had like... such a free...
We were so free!
Wait!
What the fuck!
We were actually so free!
He like told us to rotate!
Oh!
My Discord crashed.
Oh my gosh.
Looks like Discord has crashed.
Oh shit!
Why did my... Why did my Discord crash?
Wait, is Discord down for everybody?
No, it's just me.
What the fuck?
Is it just me?
Did everybody else's Discord also crash or is it just me?
I can't tell!
No!
I don't have PC Discord!
It's alright.
Thank God.
I hope everybody else's Discord crashed too.
It... It says...
Um...
It says like...
Um... I can't reload desktop Discord at the moment.
It just says...
This is awkward.
Looks like Discord has crashed unexpectedly.
We've tracked the error and we'll get right to it.
Okay, let me... Let me try and reboot Discord.
It really better.
I'm... I'm bind... I'm binded it but...
Yeah, I can't...
What?
The fuck?
Okay, that's weird.
Alright.
Where's my task manager?
Do I not have task manager?
Oh, there it is.
Is that task manager?
Okay.
Discord.
Oh God.
Okay, I'm not using... Okay, I'm gonna...
Close...
How do I... Oh my gosh, I don't know how to use Windows 11.
I...
What the fuck?
Okay.
And task.
Alright.
Time to reboot Discord.
Did it work?
Checking for updates.
Starting?
Yay!
Did it work?
Okay.
I did not leave the... I did not rage quit my team.
My Discord crashed.
Alright.
Okay, I'm back.
Nice.
Alright.
It's okay.
They didn't even notice I was gone.
That's okay.
I don't know what caused it.
It just crashed.
I don't know.
I can't believe it.
It's not me.
Saucer, like, placed... got first and also placed in his last two games.
And now he makes a poor IGL decision?
It's not me.
That's all... all I'm saying.
All I'm saying is that we should have... I stayed.
I anchored.
I made the right decision on staying.
And then my...
We were in end zone!
No!
We could have lived there!
We could have lived...
What do you mean I mind broke two people?
I had a legitimate argument.
Dogs want more than... dogs want other dog friends.
Like...
Because only a dog would understand another fellow dog.
Like... it is a legitimate argument.
Does...
Yes!
Dad has friends.
Of course he does!
Because I'm not a monster.
He actually does!
He...
Every time we take him to the salon.
He has...
He has his friends.
Yes!
He has friends other than me.
Don't...
I'm saying it.
I fixed...
Yeah, I fixed my keyboard.
All I'm saying is that...
I like...
My favorite part was like...
We're getting a cat!
And I'm like...
A cat's not a dog!
So anyway...
All I'm saying is that my argument is a legitimate argument.
To have...
Like...
Dogs need to be socialized to have...
That's why...
That's why some dogs are like...
Extra...
Extra aggressive!
Because like...
They don't...
They've never socialized with other dogs before.
So they don't know how to handle other dogs.
Because they don't never...
Uh...
They've never like...
Actually encountered other fellow dogs.
So they're like...
There's peop...
There's animals other than myself?
See?
True!
I told you!
I knew...
Now you guys see my side!
Um...
A lot of dogs that tend to be like...
Super hyper...
Super aggressive.
Tends to be like...
Dogs that haven't been able to socialize...
Um...
When they are younger.
They just...
They've just been like...
Uh...
They just like...
They don't know how to react with other...
Other canines too.
Isn't dad aggressive towards children and old people?
Yes!
Because they're children!
And...
Okay.
No.
I shouldn't...
That's not a good excuse.
Um...
Because dad sees...
He's like...
Dad sees a child and was like...
I can take them.
No.
Keep going.
Keep...
No.
No, Doki.
Keep going.
Elaborate on what you mean by...
Because they're children.
Um...
Okay.
Dad...
Hates...
Men...
Kids...
And the elderly.
Um...
It...
Uh...
But he's fine with other dogs.
Okay?
He's...
He's fine with other dogs.
That's what the conversation is about.
He's okay with other dogs.
He just has a type.
Exactly.
He just...
He's okay with other dogs.
He has...
He has a type when it comes to humans.
Um...
That's...
No.
That's not almost everyone.
Because he doesn't hate women.
He loves women.
Yeah.
Women.
Oh.
No.
He actually likes all types of women.
Just not kids and the elderly.
Just not children.
Just not...
Same.
Of course.
Yay!
Women!
He's just like me.
Look.
He has a type.
Okay?
So...
Pick him.
What about...
Um...
When he hit a certain point of old, he doesn't like them.
So, like...
Um...
It just depends on, like, how old...
How old they are.
This is not all...
I don't win for women.
Hahaha.
Dad is my spirit animal.
Okay.
Round two.
Round two, guys.
Sharko, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Dad doesn't love hags.
Look.
At a certain age.
Okay?
Okay.
But, like, what age is a hag?
Some of you guys will say 30 equals hag.
So, like...
Like, I feel like...
I feel like dad is, like...
Okay.
There's, like, a certain point.
I feel, like...
60.
Maybe.
The moment you look like...
Look like you're...
Old, old, then dad's like...
Um...
Hahaha.
Okay.
Because, I know...
Because, like, some of you guys are, like, 40.
But yet, like, you categorized mint as a hag.
And, like, I fucking hope to God she's not...
Hahaha.
I think I don't think mince 40.
I don't think mince 40.
Hag IRL versus hag online.
Okay, what's the age for an online hag versus an IRL hag?
I was like, I hope she is 40.
And okay, online hag is 30.
Jesus.
Alright, if you remember the 90s, you're a hag.
What's the male equivalent of a hag?
Actually, what's the male equivalent of a hag?
Because that's the female equivalent.
Orc?
Silver.
Gramps?
Alright, how are we looking?
I don't think... I don't think... oh wait.
I think we're pretty... we're doing alright.
Alright, same comp?
Yep.
Heezer?
Is that OG-san?
Why do you guys get the good ones?
It's like fucking OG-san and fucking hag.
Anybody else has a small dog or no?
Heezer.
I have a small dog and he has friends.
Wow, heezer.
I'm putting it out there now.
I'm a different shepherd.
You got a guard dog.
I got a big girl.
Aww.
Does your dog have friends?
Well, does your dog know your boyfriend's rank?
I mean, he's technically his dog, so I would assume.
Oh, she definitely knows that.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Oh wait, it's not even your dog.
Damn.
Cause like, you know, if you saw that dog as yours, you wouldn't say my boyfriend's dog.
You'd be like, our dog.
You wouldn't like specifically name that the dog is not even yours.
You know what's crazy?
He brought her with him.
I don't mean to like, you know, chime on this, but that's my girlfriend's dog and I said it's my dog.
Yeah, see?
He claimed the dog as his as well.
It's an our thing, not a his thing.
I call her my dog.
Sometimes I say his dog.
That shouldn't even be a thought in your head.
Damn.
I feel bad.
Hey, at least I give her the treats.
He doesn't.
Whoa.
Whoa, and yet you don't even accept it as yours.
They hate her for she spoke the truth.
So did you, did you ask your boyfriend what his rank is?
No.
Oh my God.
You haven't checked that one?
You didn't even like check after we called you out.
He's fine.
You're not even embarrassed that you don't know and you didn't even try to fix it.
Wait, what's the bottom rank of, uh, what's the bottom rank?
What if he dropped to the bottom rank?
Yeah.
What if he needs you to comfort him right now?
What if he's crying right now?
What if the boys are making fun of him?
Yeah.
What if like they're watching the stream right now and they're like, oh my God, your girlfriend doesn't even know your rank.
Right.
Wait.
Crazy.
I got this.
He's just sitting there taking it all in like I don't even want to do this no more.
Yeah.
He's just, maybe he stopped playing Overwatch and you didn't even know.
Right.
What rank are you?
Yes.
He's gold too.
Oh my, no wonder you don't want to know his rank.
Damn.
You shouldn't even have told us that.
I was catching strings for not knowing it.
You shouldn't even have told us his rank if he's gold one.
Damn.
No one is safe.
I like how through all of this, Sorcerer has just been quiet.
Is that good?
Bro, he's not even gold one, he's gold two.
Cause he doesn't want to get roasted.
He's scared.
Oh, damn.
Did you just catwood me?
I'm getting roasted here.
It's the same stuff.
Yeah, I can't wait for the Pathy recolor heirloom.
Oh my god.
Stop, he's already dead.
It'd be nice to have like all gold boxing gloves.
I thought Duke was going to improve this.
Hey, we're having a good time.
We're laughing.
That's how that matters.
We're all having a good time.
Guys, I need to let it all out.
I was, I was, I was silenced earlier.
So now I'm letting it all out.
Is the G7 Warford this year or no?
Yeah, it's pretty good.
They like buffed it.
No one is safe.
Oh, hey.
A blue flatline.
I didn't know that was possible.
Whoa.
Oh my god, purple.
Oh my god, so good.
Okay.
Not that I'm being your vent.
I need to let it out.
I let out the aggression.
Microaggression.
I'm the type of person you call HR for.
I have two blue badge numbers.
Let's see.
Are you winning?
I'm not last.
That's a win in my book.
Bro, if I find another evac, I swear.
Yeah.
Okay.
Let me find more shield cells.
Ooh.
I need that site.
Let's see.
PTS.
Oh, evac there.
I swear.
I'm just, I'm just being trolled.
That's it.
That's...
That's what I'm understanding.
I'm gonna go get the evo.
Hmm.
Let's see.
I'm gonna make sure I have everything I need.
Oh, I need to open this for loot.
I like what I got.
Is chat broken again?
I don't know what's going on.
It broke again.
I got a keyboard.
I need to go to phase driver for the main console.
Yeah.
Wait, is it...
When did it break?
Actually, I don't know this circle.
If I'm not mistaken, it's the one that's like over here.
Oh, is it?
Oh!
Oh, the overlay's broken too.
Alright, I'll fix that later.
I don't really have time to fix it at the moment.
It seems already leaving phase, I believe.
We could just evac over.
Alright, I'm gonna grab this bat and then...
What I need...
I feel like I need more energy ammo.
They're hitting the...
Um...
button.
Phase driver.
Yeah, I'm gonna drop an evac right here.
Are we all gone?
There's another evac here in the house.
Here's two evacs.
I'll grab that.
I'm so far, but I'm coming.
I don't know where to go.
Where do we go?
Oh, phase driver, phase driver.
Oh, okay.
Mirror, mirror, mirror, mirror.
Weeeing.
You wanna go backside?
Yeah.
Oh, since Discord crashed...
Oh, Discord crashed the...
Wait, did Discord crash the chat as well?
Well, just scan UAV and ring console here and then keep going.
Yep.
I don't wanna win.
I need energy ammo if you guys see any.
Inside the building.
Okay.
Scanning.
We're doing okay.
I'm gonna say that and we're gonna get fucking shit on.
That smoke scared the fuck out of me.
Do you still need energy?
Uh, yeah.
I only have some VA.
Nice.
I'm like kinda good now.
I have like 100.
Evac?
Three stacks right here.
Oh, so...
Let's get this ring console.
It sounds like kind of on us.
Ooh.
I'm scared.
I got this evo cache on the right.
So I got a sniper digi and I can see.
I'm gonna go back to the base.
There's a PK in here.
Oh, there's a people over here.
Uh, somebody over here.
Yeah, there's people over there.
I'm big balling them.
So bang.
Bang is going for care package.
Wait, I can see in the.
What?
Hello?
They can't.
They nerfed it.
No, I can see her.
I can clearly see her in the.
Yeah.
I can still see her in the smoke.
What the hell?
Are you telling us?
Kill her.
I've tried to.
But she fucking Jiminy Quickens out here.
I'm gonna pull up the hill.
Kinda.
Someone's coming.
Where are you going?
Are we just chilling here for now?
Yeah, we're chilling here.
Just hold out our space over here.
Bang drop.
Just make sure no one comes in from the west side.
I'm looking this direction.
There's nobody there.
That was an accident.
Alright guys, I'm doing...
Somebody sniped them in the head.
I'm doing recon.
I'm gonna make sure nobody's behind us.
I'm being a good reconist.
Guys, there's nobody here.
Look at that.
I should do that with cover.
Yeah, they're coming to us!
Coming to us!
Where?
Left side.
Oh, okay.
Oh, I see them!
I see them!
Blue, is there anyone?
Oh...
Reloading.
I'm gonna wrap a little bit left.
Yeah, they're wrapping left.
They're right here.
One's in smoke.
Two are in smoke.
Oh shit!
I'm up on the building on the left over here.
Yeah.
I'm gonna shot in the back there.
Do I come to you guys?
I don't see that team.
I guess I do.
They're the last team over here.
Alright, I'm going a little bit back into circle.
Someone hold this...
I'll be.
I got it.
I'm dropping an EVEM.
I'm gonna go back for it.
Oh.
Alright.
They're still over here.
We're still alive!
Yeah, they're behind that big ass wall.
I can't even see it.
Eh.
Oh!
Who's shooting me?
It's not good.
I just realized I have four shield cells.
Oh.
I see them.
55 on bang!
Alright.
I'm reloading.
Nice.
Putting down my package.
It's the non care package package.
Non care package package.
Like it.
Look at that.
So we're getting shot at, somebody's hiding right here, another person over here.
I'm playing loft over here.
Excuse me.
I'm just getting angles.
Here's a blue helmet for you.
One of you guys has a white helmet.
Got it.
Alright, so I have the 50% zip line.
Let me know where you want me to put it.
One on the left.
Save it for now.
Alright.
This one is going to be kind of rough for us.
There is a redeploy over there.
It's sad though.
Oh, take it.
Team, walk up with me Fae.
We can maybe hit ring console again.
I'm pretty sure that was this team.
I'm looking to our right just in case.
To our east.
Yeah, that team is just still on that building.
Long burn.
Oh, never mind.
Maybe just chill.
Crack them.
I'll re-smoke you any foe heal.
You guys are good.
I have a phoenix in the care package if you want it later.
I don't have any vision on anybody.
Whoa!
It's all pulled far.
Should we just hail Mary and some evacs?
Can everyone hear me?
Can everyone come to us with me here?
Yeah, give me a second.
Yeah.
Fuck, it's not another UAV we could hit.
That sucks.
I'm going all around.
Oh, shit.
I fucked up.
There's a...
Whoa!
There's a people here!
There's people here!
Over here!
A team!
Oh my god!
I'm dead!
Final?
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I got a guy coming.
They're pushing me, I think.
They're pushing Doki.
Yeah.
Doki, I saw him.
I saw contact.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Did you kill her?
They're running over here.
I don't know where they went.
I just got shot and I got scared.
Yeah, let's just go north.
They kind of stole our rotate this time.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Where the fuck did that team come from?
I don't know.
I just got scared and I inked.
What?
I put out my heal drone.
I was so scared.
All so scared.
She said I got scared and I inked.
What?
I was so scared.
I was defense mechanism.
Try to walk through the terminal and get to my yellow ping.
The buildings are there.
We can.
Team right here.
Wait.
Okay.
That's way too far.
They don't know.
Shoot on the bang.
Okay, keep walking.
Keep walking deep if we can.
I don't know why there's shields here, but...
Yo, I'm lagging.
I'm lagging too.
Yeah, I'm serving.
Yeah, no, the server is dog shit.
Keep in front of me.
Hold team.
Shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot.
Come back.
Oh, God.
Oh, no.
Come back to where we...
Yeah, come back to the entrance we came from.
Okay.
I'm scared.
Good luck.
We're fine.
All right, we're just going to evac here into the compound.
All right.
Wait.
Somebody died to a ring.
What a nerd.
Ma'am.
I'm going to tell them you said that.
Where are we going?
Yellow ping compound.
I hope it's free, but I have no info.
So...
If it's taken to swerve, but it looks good to me.
It does not look good.
It's lifeline talking back.
Oh, fuck.
Yeah, I'm just going to be on that line over here.
On the left side over here.
Start setting up walls over here on me.
I'm bang on taking that team to get pressure off of you.
No.
I got it.
I'll rez.
Or you rez.
Pass one.
Nate.
Oh, my God.
Get the reser again.
Reser again.
Fine.
There's so many.
Woo.
Nades.
More nades.
Dude.
Yeah, that's a fuse team.
More nades.
Fuse.
I just need my walls up.
I'm begging.
I need this.
So many nades.
So many fuse.
Start setting up walls.
Oh, my God, dude.
They're here.
Yeah, that sucks.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
You're the only one left.
Just hide.
Did you hide?
Oh, my God, he's still alive.
Oh, my God.
Boy, were there so many nades.
Why were there so many?
You clutched your stress all day?
Yeah.
Oh my god!
That would be crazy if you get this rez!
There's a vengel behind us, we can maybe 3p that.
Oh my god, he's doing it!
Where do we go?
I don't see anything.
I see smokes, but...
I don't know if they're really fighting.
I don't know, but we need to find a safe spot.
Oh, I'm stuttering.
I don't have walls.
There's a shield right here, maybe we need to fight this.
They're fighting, they're fighting!
We need to commit this!
Watch out!
Behind us!
Okay, I see that.
I'm backing out.
Come to me and put chill.
The team is getting 3p'd.
I'm lagging so bad.
No, this is our servers.
The whole team is running down to 3p it.
I can't move.
Holy fuck, the server is dying.
The shield right here is set up walls.
What the fuck, I can't move!
One minute, thanks, Nerf War.
Why is anybody shooting?
Come on!
They're fighting on the left.
I'm gonna try to get involved.
Full team dead, full team dead.
Their second team is still alive.
I'm backing up, I'm backing up, I'm backing up.
Bro, I still see people in the fucking smoke.
What the fuck is going on?
The server is back to normal.
Fucking 80 years later.
I got red shields, I'm chilling.
We're getting smoked.
I don't see anything.
I'm fucking legally blind.
They're walking, they're walking, they're walking.
I'm getting banned.
Do you have Q?
Yeah.
I have no shields.
I need some fucking loot.
This team is moving, they're moving to that team.
They're moving to this team.
They're fighting, they're fighting this team to our right.
They're fighting, they're pushing.
Lifeline is late.
Zed's gonna start closing, get the kills.
Cracked, cracked, cracked, cracked.
I don't know who I cracked though.
Lifeline, you cracked Lifeline.
Oh, I don't see them now.
They're moving to us.
Just hold them out.
Close, close, close to the war.
Close on this fucking face to the left.
They're pushing, they're pushing.
Flash one, flash one.
I died, I died here.
Reloading.
No, I'm being fucked.
That's gonna kill me.
She's behind you, she's in the ring.
She's gonna die.
What the fuck?
There's a guy in the loot box.
Behind you, full dead, full dead.
I'm dead.
A lot of people looking at me.
Oh my god.
One guy was hiding in the bin while I got bingled.
These zone pulls are kinda crazy.
This guy gets to chill?
This team gets to just chill here?
It's not fair.
I didn't even see the pathee.
He was literally like...
I got stunned by the bangle.
And then like...
I couldn't see him.
It was like, blur.
Oh my god.
That was actually a crazy zone.
Yeah, the bangle fucking stunned me so I couldn't see the...
Yeah, he blended into...
into the bin itself.
Also, we were poor as hell.
We were so poor.
We had nothing.
This is not fair.
Did he get to just sit here?
He gets to just sit here and not worry about the other team.
He got to worry about the war outside?
Oh yeah, I gotta fix my foogie in chat.
Give me a sec.
Just wanna remind you guys.
And then...
They should fix it.
I'm pretty sure.
They should start bouncing soon.
And I'll fix my chat too.
And then...
There you go.
You guys are fixed!
Alright.
But not that type of fix.
Uh...
Not like that.
You guys are back!
Where is that?
Alright.
I'll be right back.
I'm gonna use the bathroom.
I'll be right back, guys.
Alright, I'm back.
Does this mean dad hates almost all...
No!
You guys can...
You guys can fix him.
You know?
You know how you're like, I can fix her?
You guys can be like, I can fix dad.
You're like, I can fix him.
I'll be the exception.
Unless you're a lady goon.
Then don't worry.
You already got the free pass.
Dad already loves you.
You're your goal.
We can't...
At least, never last though.
Now that I think about it...
How the hell were we gonna get in a good rotation?
We weren't.
That was the funny part.
Hahaha!
It was just survive.
Just survive.
That's it.
Which we didn't do very well.
Hahaha!
Damn.
I mean, that race was crazy though!
We placed higher.
We didn't get any money, but we placed higher.
Hahaha!
Oh my god, that poor team.
Jesus Christ.
That poor team.
Fucking high ground shit.
This team has fucking high ground.
Oh my god.
That poor... poor fucking team.
GG's a drop.
Dropped what?
The fuck?
How can he... Why can't he survive when he played with us?
Hahaha!
He died first the last two games I had!
And he lives here!
Hahaha!
Drop couldn't do this earlier!
It was my endgame!
Dropped!
Where the fuck is my endgame?
Hahaha!
Oh my god.
GG's though.
GG's.
GG's?
It was fun playing with you all.
Yeah.
GG's.
Nice meeting you guys.
Okay.
On to the next team.
Alright.
Saucer gets to stay here because he's the fucking pro player.
Next team.
We have...
Yurise!
Aprez!
Yujin and Doki.
That's me!
I'm Doki!
Hey!
We played with Yurise before!
We played with him before!
Okay.
Yurise is team 3.
Alright.
I'm just gonna shimmy over to here.
How do I shimmy over here?
How do I get over there?
I don't know how to get over there.
How do you shimmy yourself to unassigned?
Leave team!
Oh my god.
I figured it out guys.
Okay.
We need somebody on Yurise's team.
Yeah!
We played with Aprez before.
We talked about...
We talked about MILF Island!
I remember!
Aprez!
We talked about MILF MILF Manor?
Was it MILF Manor?
The one with the fucking moms!
Do you guys remember that?
That conversation we had about that reality show?
Where like all the moms and their like sons were trapped on an island.
And the sons were dating each other's moms.
And like Aprez watched it.
And he watched it.
And then I was having a discussion with him about it.
Because all I saw was the trailer.
I didn't think someone was actually gonna watch it.
And he watched it.
So I was like Oh it's coming back to me now.
I remember MILF Island.
Oh yes.
Yes.
Yes it's a real reality TV show.
Where like the moms like were you know with other their son.
Oh my gosh it was I didn't realize somebody would actually do that show.
That show was wild.
That was a wild show that's for sure.
It was definitely wild.
Wait there's a season 2 of the dad?
There's no way.
Wait.
I need to look it up now.
I'll join a voice chat later.
No.
The season 2.
MILF Matter.
There's only like one.
There's two.
There is a season two.
Wait is it actually?
Barbie is a former stripper who currently works as a marketing executive.
No.
Season 2 is still moms.
Guys.
No it is!
There's dads now!
They added dads!
Oh my god!
They added Anthony!
Son of Jo- They added dads?
They added dads who brought their sons.
Oh my god!
They brought their sons!
Okay.
Can't believe they added dads.
Change.
You're good right?
It's about to change.
I'm so freaking cooked this tourney bro.
I got overstimulated the last two games.
I like started like breaking down and shutting up.
Oh shit.
You're good.
Hello.
Alright.
Let's see.
What's up Doki?
Long time too!
Now we're playing NA instead of GP!
True.
The tables have turned.
Oh my god!
Apriz!
I've talked to you before!
I don't know if you- Yeah fuck you.
He's just ignoring you.
Oh he's ignoring us?
Bro what a bitch!
I was asking if you were back!
Oh did you?
And you didn't even say back!
You didn't even say back!
Apriz do you remember the last conversation we had?
The last time we got in a team together?
Yeah.
You remember what we talked about?
Cause I was telling my chat cause I remember what we talked about.
Cause you watched Milk Manor right?
Oh that's not me.
Oh now you remember!
Do you know they made a season 2?
Yeah would you eat today Yuj?
They had a dad!
Yeah they had a dad!
They're literally fucking dads!
They had a dad!
Yo Yuj how you been today bro?
So is it Milk Manor now?
No no they added- so like instead of just moms and their sons they brought in dads and their sons.
So the moms can pick either a dad or a son to bang.
So...
The whole family's there.
Yeah the whole family's there.
In the end they're all getting moms.
In the end.
Wow.
Yeah.
Yeah guys.
I totally know what you guys are talking about.
I feel so fucking like...
Yeah man the moms!
It's basically an American reality TV show.
Yeah yeah like American I'm out of that conversation.
What do you guys wanna play?
Um...
Don't mind us just talking about it.
Rampart is actually really good.
So whoever can play Rampart shall take Rampart.
Um...
Rampart Bang Who do you play?
Who are you comfortable with?
Lifeline.
Lifeline?
Okay.
Alright Lifeline.
Where were you joking?
I don't know.
What works in quads?
In quads it's um...
What worked really well was Rampart and Bang.
Alright.
I'm curious what are you gonna play?
I spaced out I'm gonna be completely honest.
Okay we're not gonna win anything.
No no no.
If you need a Rampart like if we... If no one's playing Rampart I can play Rampart.
Okay yeah you're a Rampart.
And then... Well Yuris what are you playing then?
Uh... I can play Bang.
Then what the fuck?
What's the fourth player?
What am I?
I'm thinking...
Then what's the third?
We have either a beacon like a Path or a Blood or a Seer.
I don't think I've seen anybody play Bloodhound during this entire...
Hey we got third last time with the Blood.
Oh we got third last time with Blood?
Not first though.
That's fucking...
That's true.
Okay yeah well I can do Blood.
I'll do Blood.
We'll see how it goes.
What about Path?
Wait what... Wait wait wait wait wait.
What about Path and I... I play Path and you play Bang.
I play Bang?
Okay.
So we... Yes!
No okay alright he's cooking he's cooking.
We're cooking we're cooking.
Yeah yeah yeah.
Alright bring your...
your berries down a little bit.
Alright and then...
We're doing Path...
Bang...
Rampart...
and Lifeline.
Yeah.
Yeah yeah yeah yeah.
Wait so what do you mean by over-simulated last two games?
What happened last two games?
Yeah what happened?
Oh I mean they're just talking normally and like started getting really...
I don't know.
I don't know what went wrong.
I just stopped thinking like and I stopped talking.
Wait what team were you on?
It was um...
I mean no they're all like nice people.
It was Zainu and...
Nah nah nah nah.
Who was it?
Call him out!
It was literally Zainu, Entity, and RainyD.
Oh it was Zainu of course.
No of course.
I don't know who he is but of course.
Maybe he was... Judging from his name I expected.
I know he's a roller player too so it makes sense.
It makes sense yeah.
And he's controller.
Wait we're all M and K right?
God.
It's over.
Maybe it was the testosterone.
It's so over.
GG guys.
I have a controller though.
No you have a controller and there's a reason why you stuck with M and K after that.
Oh shit.
But didn't Reject win?
Did he win?
That is true!
Did we win this?
That is true.
Are you saying a reject right now?
Yeah we are.
That is exactly what she's saying.
One of you guys is Sangjin and the other is...
Wait who's the coach?
Yeah who's the coach?
We have no coach.
It's over.
We don't even have a coach.
GG.
Oh my god.
It's so over.
Guys...
Wait what are we landing?
Do we even have a spot?
Yuris what are we landing?
Yes yes Dragos Dragos Dragos.
Don't worry.
What if we get contested Yuris?
Nah they won't contest us.
They don't know that.
They probably do.
They probably know!
Because they're like I didn't die in one second.
They're M and K.
They see you wall bounce and then like whiff and they're like oh M and K.
Yeah true.
They see us walk and it's not in a straight line and it's gonna be like M and K.
That guy's strafing.
That is M and K.
Oh my god.
And if it somehow turns into World's Edge we have...
No.
We have Broken Moon.
We have...
Well I heard they improved Broken Moon so...
Yeah it's actually not bad.
Yeah.
It's better than fucking stuffing all of us in King's Canyon.
That was scary.
True.
That was King's Canyon.
There's too many people in King's Canyon.
Two more games!
Two more games chat!
And then...
Dry Gulch.
And then we... it's off to work.
I know where that is.
I mean I'm still...
Top left pretty much.
Okay.
And then if it's World's Edge...
No we're doing Broken Moon.
What?
Happy server.
Yeah if it... apparently it bugs to World's Edge sometimes.
Oh!
Oh are we playing through if it bugs to World's Edge?
Yeah.
Oh we are?
Okay.
Nice.
I hope it does.
World's Edge is better.
But we gotta get some of the other maps low.
We talked about that.
Look that was like my only thing...
Cause like none of us...
Cause like nobody watched Milt Manor except for you.
That's why I remembered it.
Cause like we were just talking about the trailer and you're like I watched the entire season of Milt Manor.
And then that like...
That like left an impression on me.
Wait Milt Manor?
Yeah that's what it's called!
Oh I thought it was Miss Hearing Shit.
That was actually called Milt Manor.
Yeah you can google it!
Oh my god.
It's fucking lit bro.
It's fucking lit!
Wait did you watch season 2?
No I haven't even gotten that far.
Was season 1 good enough to watch through the entire thing?
It was good enough for him!
Yeah but were you watching it more for the lols?
It's just so dumb.
There's like a guy in there that's just like fully chat.
He's like what's up bro?
Hot single moms dive into a unique dating experience.
Oh my god.
And he watched the entire season!
But aren't you also the guy who oh-wo-ifies everything?
Wait what?
Is that not you?
No it's not me.
I see your titles and it's like...
Oh my god he's rewriting history.
Okay so the thing is he's willing to own up to Milt Manor but he's not willing to own up to oh-wo.
It's a command my mods made and they like uwu my titles.
It's my mods!
Blaming the mods.
I heard the viewers reflect the streamers.
Yeah that's true!
That's true!
You cultivate your chat!
That's crazy.
Your mods do it for free and you're blaming them?
Oh god.
Yeah look at that.
I pay them in experience.
Oh!
You're gonna be their references.
They're gonna call you up as a reference.
Yeah.
I'll give them a good review.
I'll vouch.
You'll vouch.
People have actually used like moderators to apply for jobs I think.
Oh shit.
You guys hear that mods?
You can use us as references.
Cause it shows leadership qualities.
No.
I'll give you a bad reference.
What the hell?
Oh god.
She wants you to stay forever.
Yeah I don't want you guys to leave so...
You're not allowed to make money.
Gatekeeping.
My mods.
They're my mods.
They're not gonna improve their jobs.
Yeah.
That is true.
There is a lot of...
There is a lot of um...
management going on in the chat.
It's a very chaotic place.
Yeah.
You could like exaggerate.
How would you exaggerate like managing chat?
Yeah.
What would you put down there?
Your boss is gonna be like What's a Twitch stream?
Yeah.
Um.
I actually volunteer in a community of um...
A lot of people.
We're doing KC?
No!
What about World's End?
You lied to!
No!
What is your KC spot, Yuris?
Uh...
We got runoff and bunker town.
Oh.
Okay.
I turned down Yuris and turned up a praise aim word.
Oh wait.
That's on your marriage.
Oh thank you!
You finally!
I know you like proposed but...
You finally married married?
Yeah.
I got married.
It was quite a long time ago.
It's kinda like at the same time.
Yeah but I never said anything.
No.
You're good.
In like a call.
So I just wanted to congratulate you.
Yeah.
Appreciate it.
Thank you.
Little love bird.
You're like way younger than me and already married.
That's not making any sense.
Nah.
Damn.
You gotta make it all about you.
Yeah.
I make everything about me.
I'm sorry.
Like the last time we played, I was like a little kid.
That was crazy.
Yeah.
You were like 18.
Damn.
I don't even remember how young I was because it didn't matter.
You were just a baby.
Oh my god.
You had all the rank days.
Yeah.
I know he got engaged.
I didn't know.
Yeah.
I didn't know he got... I didn't know like finalized married married.
What's going on here?
Yeah.
What is going on here?
I don't know.
I have...
No clue.
It's bugged.
Please.
We still have two more games.
This has more delays than scrims, please.
Yeah.
We got two games to win.
Have any of you guys won your game yet?
Hell no.
Nah.
Listen... I used... Have any of you guys got last place?
No.
I got last place.
I got 20th first place.
Listen, I watched the VOD.
That was entirely Greek's fault.
Was it really Greek spot?
It was really Greek spot.
I need to watch that spot.
No!
I'm getting a new lobby!
Let me pick my character so I don't fucking...
Oh, true.
Lean custom match.
Well, I kind of thought like...
in a retrospect that I also like...
you know, I landed like right side.
I was like looting for a little bit too long.
And then I like waddle up as Caustic.
And then I start shooting a Prowler.
But I didn't realize that I was gonna shoot my Prowler...
instead of my RE45.
So my aim goes really skewpy.
Yeah, so then I was like...
Oh gosh.
It's me.
It's my fault.
No.
Oh, Nuko's out.
Alright.
Damn.
Greek knew what he was shooting.
I'm getting like a scoop.
They're saying Greek did 19 damage?
Damn!
Greek did 19 damage?
Just snitching on us.
Just snitching on us dumbass bruh.
Damn!
Yeah, to be fair...
that game I did 54 damage.
Yeah, yeah.
As long as you're not the lowest...
that's all that matters.
I was better than him.
He used to be pro.
Yeah, he used to be a pro player.
That's why he's a character.
As I turn down your ACS.
Oh my N.
Sorry.
I believe in this team.
As long as we get a house, we can sit all the way to 6th place.
And do nothing.
That's all we need.
6th place?
We're gonna aim for higher.
Look.
I didn't even get to at least 6th place.
I need that 6th place.
I got one 6th.
Our top rating was 7th.
I think my top rating was like 8th or 9th.
I don't know.
Oh my N.
But I killed a person.
Okay.
We have Yurise who plays a lot of rank and a lot of scrims.
So you guys should know end zone.
You guys should know where the house is.
The ideal house.
I have not touched comp in about...
We both haven't.
We both haven't touched comp in a long time.
You know what the rank end zone is.
That's all that matters.
Can we bring a coach in, Nicole?
Yeah, can we?
Can we bring a coach in?
Can I like FaceTime Wig and just show him this?
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
Call Wig right now.
Yes, do it.
Do it.
Call him right now.
Get your phone down and call him.
Put him on the mic.
What?
Do it.
He won't be able to hear you though.
It's fine.
If you want to relay the mess, call him right now.
Alright, let's see if he answers.
If he doesn't answer, he's not a real friend.
He's pretty fake.
Oh god.
If he doesn't answer your call, I'll call him and see if he answers mine.
I'm really fucked up.
Because I have his phone number too.
He's not going to answer.
Oh my god.
He's not.
This fake fuck.
He actually doesn't answer you.
Oh my god.
You try.
Nah, nah.
You do it.
If he answers, that's crazy.
That's crazy if he answers.
Oh my god.
Wait, okay.
I'm going to call.
I'm going to call and see.
Okay, guys.
Okay, let's see.
I need to find his number.
Oh, he's calling me.
Oh, oh.
Hello?
Yeah, we don't know zones.
Can I FaceTime you and just show you the zone?
Doki?
Doki was asking us that we better know zone.
But we don't know shit.
We need a coach.
Yeah, we need a coach.
Coach us.
Yeah, I got Doki Bird.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, shit.
He did 14 damage?
Oh, damn.
That's fucked up.
That's a lie.
He said Tempo would do better than me.
Just say it straight up.
Okay, but it's not because of me.
It's not me.
Love you.
By the way, do you think my toilet is still a great toilet?
It's still stained for your Panda Express.
I didn't stain it.
I'm supposed to be.
What is happening right now?
Nah, bro.
That's all him, not me.
Alright, yeah, bye-bye.
He didn't even say love you.
He did.
Oh, he did?
Okay, I was gonna say it.
I'd be fucked up if he didn't say it back.
He said I stained Greek's toilet.
Did you?
I don't think so.
Oh my god, that is not a no.
That is not a no.
That's not a no.
I mean, I might have.
What the fuck did you eat?
Because I ate Panda Express from the airport.
Oh my god.
At the airport?
Yeah, I was hungry.
Oh my god, you probably pay Greek.
I gotta pay to use this toilet?
Yeah, that one.
It's like a toll.
That's crazy.
That's crazy that Wiggs said that though.
He said, he instantly said his GG's.
Yeah.
In every game you did 14 damage.
That is not true.
No trust.
Now I was watching the Challenger Circuit.
They did well.
Yeah, we did so well.
You guys went to day two.
Yeah, we went.
Yeah, you almost got to day three.
Yeah, we almost made it to the finals.
Wigg was supposed to sign us up for the next Challenger Circuit, but he forgot.
Of course he didn't.
So yeah, I've...
What is going on?
What's taking so long?
Are we not there yet?
I think the servers are broken or something.
Have you guys been lagging by the way?
Yeah, no, the servers are fucked.
Mine is said we were on Dallas, but uh...
Yeah, I have like the lowest ping of like 90.
It like fucks up in the middle of the game too.
That's the thing.
Like everybody's ping just...
Yeah, packet loss and ping in the middle of fights.
Which was crazy.
Uh...
Yeah, someone told me I won Clip Timmy, and then I was like, oh, but was it like...
Did I like only win because of ping spike?
And then I had to look back on the bot.
So was it because of ping or was it pure skill?
Oh, no!
Oh, there he goes.
Damn, you should play one.
That's your moment.
That's your moment right there.
He bleeds.
Yeah, I mean I was...
He's not a perfect being.
But honestly, it was about time I got revenge because he shits on me every fucking turn or like content creator like match or whatever.
I just get bullied and beat around and that was my one...
My one vengeance.
That's why you gotta put yourself as...
Like when they sign up, it'd be like, what's your highest rank?
Yeah, I'll put like plat or something so you get to be... have like the lowest expectations.
Yeah, but most of the times I already feel like I am the weakest link in most lobbies.
It's okay, I'm here now.
No, no, no.
Literally!
Didn't you... didn't you recently get like top 500 in Overwatch?
No, that wasn't...
That wasn't like season one in Overwatch 2.
There's...
It's season 10 in Overwatch 2 now!
You can do it again!
You're like a FPS like god.
Bro, the last time I played Apex was two weeks ago!
Oh god damn.
Oh god.
We might be cooked.
Should we just teabag if we see a team and then they'll let us go?
No, they're just gonna shoot us.
These guys really want that $700.
Yeah, they have this money involved.
Yeah.
There's money involved.
I literally made more via super chats on my YouTube stream than I...
Damn!
You said you broke box?
No!
I'm saying, even if I win zero prize money...
That's crazy!
If I win zero prize money here...
Shit!
My Dragoons got me.
So it feels like I'm winning.
Oh, I see.
They're donating prize money to me.
Oh, okay.
Participation is a reward, you know?
Yeah.
Okay, so like I told my chat this, but Tempo is actually holding at least 10k worth of prize money for me because I forgot to fill in the tax form.
Jesus.
Oh my god.
Because I participated in so many of Tempo's tournaments, so like I never filled the tax form.
To receive it.
Oh!
You got a game!
Let's freaking go.
Let's go, let's go.
You guys know who you're playing, right?
Yeah, Bangalore.
Yeah.
I'm Rampart.
Yeah, you're on Rampart duty.
Yeah, I got it.
You guys got me, right?
Even if I don't win prize money.
Yeah, I think it was from like End of Seasons event last season.
Because we can't keep giving more money to Tempo's bank account.
Yeah.
It's me.
A spendy.
A whale.
Damn.
We don't look very intimidating.
Don't say that.
What do you mean?
All our skins.
They don't look scary at all.
I have a pink skin.
That's so scary.
Faker does not use skin.
Yeah, but he has a $500 skin.
Where's our $500 skin?
Wait, I don't want to beat your master.
I don't know where we're going.
Oh!
What happened?
What bugged out?
What happened, bro?
Yes.
I've been watching for 20 years.
Oh my god.
It's been so long.
I'm screaming.
Oh my god.
Why?
Why didn't we start?
I had bacon.
Question mark.
I can't believe we don't even have a coach to tell us where endgame is.
Thank you Bin.
Thank you guys for getting me.
Even if we don't get any prize money.
Wait, who crashed?
Somebody crashed.
Someone on Drop's team crashed, but now Kimmy's team is spamming their 4th.
Because I think they're AFK.
She's back.
Oh, okay.
Wait, more than one person crashed.
Jesus.
Oh no.
Yes!
Finally!
Oh my god.
You're finally here.
I already have red bars.
Yeah.
No, I'm good.
My PC's okay.
Oh my god, we're finally here.
It's okay.
We bonded as a team.
Guys, see?
I knew I could get back into the groove, guys.
I told you.
It just took a while.
Also, feel free to yell at me for anything.
Don't yell at me though.
Like, I'm trying my best, but I might be a bit slow.
Oh my god.
Bro, love yourself.
It is true.
Love yourself.
Oh, okay.
I'll try.
You gotta try to love yourself.
Bro!
Bro, you're gonna rip more than Ernie.
I wasn't feeling the best.
Oh my god.
And now I'm feeling a lot worse.
What hurt you?
Uh, you know...
I don't think we should trauma dumb.
We should lock her up.
Oh my god.
I think we have a space port too.
Yeah, I was gonna ask that.
Okay.
He's just letting me for real.
For real.
Oh my god.
I think we have it.
Okay.
Oh yeah.
Maybe.
I can't do anything, right?
So I just land?
I don't got no bins?
No.
Yeah, where do I land?
I'm landing here.
Yeah?
Oh wait.
Yeah.
I think you got it.
It's Doki.
Nevermind.
Yeah.
Doki, you land in this side.
Alright.
You and I, you just land in that side.
Okay.
I got you guys.
Alright.
Here we go.
It all began when I was born.
Okay.
There's an evac tower here.
Nice.
We need those.
Okay.
Try to think of what guns to put.
Ooh.
We need a long... I mean we have... we have a rampage, but I'd rather not use a rampage.
Okay.
Give me actually... oh there we go.
Nice.
Okay.
Vault.
Carbine.
Nice.
We're good.
We're cooking.
Another evac tower?
Nice.
We have cheese.
Oh, Havoc?
Versatile energy weapon.
Any cheesers?
Oh.
Cheese to me, Evo.
Cheese?
Cheese what?
Harvester.
Evo Harvester.
Oh, any Harvester?
Oh.
I don't think I've ever heard somebody call it that.
Like, the fuck?
Wait.
What the heck?
I swear that's how they call it.
I'm dropping a bit of energy and a blue mag here.
No, just call it Evo.
Oh, I thought you were talking about the horses, Ron.
Aren't you a source?
Maybe... do they call that in Japanese?
Nah.
What do they call it in Japanese?
In NA?
They actually do say Evo.
Oh, Evo.
Yeah.
Maybe I got my sources from Japan, too.
True.
We don't have any?
That is...
Sad.
They're asking us to play on hard mode.
Hard mode?
What's hard mode?
You know...
No Evo...
M&K...
Oh!
True.
We need every help.
We need more money.
Temple hates one of us.
Or all of us.
And that's why she put all of us on the team together.
Where's the other one?
Can you open one of those bins?
I'll be able to scan the...
Yeah.
I'm heading over there now.
Okay.
Oh!
We don't even have a zone beacon.
Evac tower here.
They're not even trying to hide it.
Oh my God.
Why don't we grab that 3x?
Oh!
What the fuck?
Oh you want me to?
Who was there?
I don't know if they're close.
I'm just trying to heal.
I'm heading over to your East right now.
I left.
He's dead if he stays.
Alright.
Do we somehow have a zone that we don't know about?
Jesus.
Not even in core?
Okay.
Someone call Wig again.
Someone...
We need him.
I'm out of here.
Careful.
Oh my God.
Where did you get shot?
Yeah.
Go towards...
Go towards the...
Hold on.
I have to heal.
Yeah.
I'll watch for you.
Oh my God.
We're white armor.
Please.
Be gentle.
Shots in core.
So we're going for the cheese?
Yes.
The Eva.
The left side?
I'll go take it alone.
Start looking into core.
Maybe set up this building.
Okay.
There's an extra bat in here.
I'm chilling.
I have four.
I'm gonna take it.
Yeah.
I think he needs it the most.
I have...
I just used a lot.
I have one.
Are they still chasing you?
I can drop...
Nah.
They're not chasing.
Oh.
We are chilling.
You want me?
I think we have the zone close somehow.
Do you want me to heal?
Do you want to be a tactical or alt cooldown?
Tactical.
All right.
It depends.
I always ask for Bing because it depends on the pro player.
Put down my ulti for some men.
Wait.
Right here.
Close.
Oh.
What the fuck?
Wait.
Let's fight this.
Fight this.
On me.
He's on the roof, I think.
He's right here.
On the shallow roof.
I heard someone close.
Oh.
There's one on you?
What?
Yeah.
Right here.
It's a rampart.
Wait.
I can't.
The angles are just too much.
Yeah.
I could.
And I got shot in the side.
63.
Oh.
Nice shot.
Wait.
Do we have to zip?
I think we have the zone.
Wait.
They zipped over.
Oh.
Wait.
Right side.
He fell down.
There's one right here.
I see that.
Wait.
A whole team.
Yeah.
They're playing the zip.
They're running it.
They're valking.
There's so many people.
They're going to valk all this team.
Yeah.
They should.
This.
Okay.
I'm going to valk.
Idiot.
No flash.
Aw.
Yeah.
I think the zone is somehow going fucking where we came from.
I think it was on us.
Yeah.
I'm pretty sure.
That sucks.
I got through this tunnel.
And we can control this height right here.
We could have stayed in the house.
We could have.
People literally gave us a house.
All right.
It happens.
I have a fortnite.
I'm going to get a fortnite.
You have any more bats, if anyone needs?
Yeah, I need one.
OK.
Pretty sure there's...
Yeah.
There's spots here.
There's some good spots to our left.
There's, like, a really deep rock you can play in.
Yeah.
All right.
We just play here for now.
Okay.
Wait.
There's a wall.
Is that our lifeline pack or is that someone else?
No.
There's a team here.
No, no.
There's someone else.
We did not...
We can go up here, Urisse.
It's, like, a good spot.
Up here?
Oh.
What the heck?
Oh, what is this zone?
Wait, yeah, we definitely...
We can go like right here.
Yo, this is... we're vibing.
Yeah.
Not that far left.
Yeah, we're not vibing that far.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They could peek this right here though.
That kind of sucks.
There's a team in bridge.
You can even go more up here.
Oh, apartment.
What the f...
Okay, we gotta make presence here though.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
People might just roll up here because we're hiding there.
I'm gonna put this wall to our left.
Okay, out the left.
Oh my god, we can put four walls?
How many walls can I put up?
Five.
Looks like people are here.
I knocked one.
Oh, damn, Thurston!
Wait, we might be able to get to Thurston.
He's right here.
Oh, he's like deep in that.
Yeah, the most I can do is just hit their Watson Gen.
Yeah.
All good.
Okay.
I really should know that Watson Gen who's boss.
Damn.
Make them waste their ulti cells.
Alright, I'm gonna chill.
I have 140 heavy.
Oh, I can drop you some up.
254.
Dude, it was in our building.
I'm so sad.
It really was.
This is the second time I've gotten zoned with no zone knowledge.
It's so annoying.
Unlucky.
Actually cursed.
I mean, I feel like that was a sign when we had team literally Mach 7 you over there.
True.
It is kind of hard to hold like over there though.
That's true.
We could take like a second floor but...
Yeah, I feel like Cat would have been better if we wanted to hold like a room over there.
Yeah.
But it's okay.
Maybe zone will flip on us.
We'll see the zone.
Yeah, maybe we'll be lucky.
Yeah, we can't be that unlucky, right?
Yeah.
The 4M and K team.
With no beacons.
What?
How did I break my wall?
Did you break your own wall?
There's a guy right here that I can barely see.
I feel like we need a new wall.
Come on.
The guy right here is really...
Got a minute.
Can we somehow evac...
Okay, we're not evacing from there.
Okay, we can evac from here.
Alright, moment of truth.
Yeah.
Never mind in a minute.
I thought I did rest when we were in the slow side.
Oh.
It would be so funny if I had a shot there.
Warming.
M and K noob.
Are you like...
Oh, that guy's red armor.
The team on the... what?
The team has red.
That's kinda crazy.
Bro, where did he get red?
Is this hell?
You're a rat.
Oh no, it started.
Not the fuse.
Oh no.
The only thing that can hurt us.
Nades.
I'm bad.
Ten seconds.
If we have to do anything...
These guys are just.
Standing still.
Wait, that safe?
What?
Oh, shit!
Oh, we're still trying to be.
Oh, wait, this is not right.
I don't know if there's still someone here.
You can put the second guy in.
There's like walls over here on the low ground.
Should be able to play that.
Because this bridge team can't really peek towards us like once we're on this low ground.
Yeah.
106.
Dead.
I killed one here.
Oh nice.
Thirsty or just not?
Yeah, we can't really rest now.
Oh, I'm just gonna stay with you.
Yeah, that guy's just...
I'm wasting my shield cells just healing.
On this next zone close, we're just gonna play the low ground.
We gotta wait for Preez's walls.
Why we have walls?
We can probably play the like the low ground of the bridge too later like over here.
Should I place my package for mid?
Uh, yeah, yeah, I don't think we're gonna get hurt.
Should I place it low ground?
Yeah, place it like right here.
Team VOD voting.
Where they're going.
All right.
What is that spot?
Ah, I gotta get it for you.
Whoa, don't shoot me.
What do you need?
We're just vibing.
We have more shields.
In bats?
Well, I got three bats but five cells but I'm spamming my sentinel.
Thank you.
I'm just vibing.
Team here.
There's a whole team here.
Yeah.
Uh, team here.
Oh, I'm scared.
Should we start setting up?
Yeah.
Yeah, my fault.
All right.
Oh, I like this.
I like this pack.
This is scary.
Yeah.
Yeah, there's still a team this way.
That team should get pinched like this team playing this.
I think they're just playing the building and then that platform over there.
Okay.
We can even play the low ground of this later too.
All right.
Yeah.
Team playing this.
I don't see anybody.
They're all just very far.
Oh.
Yeah, I think we're gonna play the low ground of this bridge.
That was our house.
What the fuck?
Oh.
That was scary.
I can drone.
Oh, no.
All right.
Fine.
Why are they not shooting that team in the bridge?
Hello?
Maybe they have a secret alliance.
That guy shot me at the gap.
I was like not expecting that.
Wait, he just...
Oh.
What the...
88.
Let's see if I can...
Try coming down and...
Yeah.
Oh, no.
Hopping.
I have the bat.
Putting drone on you too.
Yeah.
I can't see.
I just caught...
I can't see either.
Nade, nade, nade.
You're nading, nading.
Yeah.
We're good, we're good, we're good.
We're here.
Oh, I'm not good.
I am...
We're gonna just go in there.
We're gonna...
Oh, I'm dead again.
I was trying to shoot them.
No audio.
Nice.
That was cool.
Oh, no.
I win these.
Yep.
That was cool.
I didn't think they were gonna push us.
That was really fucking cool.
Actually, no audio.
Holy shit.
Where did he come from?
Yep.
No way.
Oh, my God.
Wait.
What the fuck was the Watson team on the left platform?
Hello?
What?
I don't know.
I guess we just left.
I didn't know it was one team.
I guess so.
I didn't either.
We would have just played like...
Yeah.
We could have moved out so much.
I don't know where that team on the left went.
Yeah.
I was so surprised.
It came out of nowhere.
It was a different team.
And I never heard that.
It was.
100%.
Nope.
They didn't fight.
What?
Yeah, we have another game.
We have another game.
Just no audio.
Yeah, that was just...
That's not on us.
That's not MNK.
That's on audio.
That was crazy.
I...
I actually have never...
I was...
Guys.
At least not last, guys.
At least not last.
True.
No, they had the freeze rotate.
What the fuck?
I don't know where everyone went on this side.
Yeah, I don't know.
I don't know where they went.
Straight up.
I hope they die.
That could have been our house right there.
Yes.
I hope they die.
Me too.
I hope they die seventh.
So they never think...
Oh, peek down.
Yes, peek down.
No, why are you not peeking down?
Die seventh.
Come on.
Yes.
Kill them.
Come on.
Make it seem like they're gonna get placement money.
Apex...
Oh my god.
Where did that team on the left go?
What?
Not only did we not get our house, we got audioed so hard.
Yeah.
And everybody rotated away.
Ugh.
What the fuck.
They get such a free run.
Okay.
But maybe we just get all our bad luck out of the way.
And get a win.
Yeah.
And then next game, we have a comeback.
That's why I think I agree with that.
When you say that, you sound so depressed as if you don't believe.
It's hard to like, believe in that plan.
That's just my state of being.
Oh my god!
Is this why you play... you still play?
Yeah.
That's why I've been taking a break from Apex Legends.
Shit!
Yesterday was like my first time in a couple weeks playing.
Oh shit.
That's too real.
That's too real, man.
Oh my god, they might die seventh!
That's all I wanted!
Yes!
The lifeline of death!
No!
Die seventh!
They got seventh!
No!
They got seventh.
What is happening?
Why are they giving such free res's?
Res's are 10 times.
This lifeline is actually carrying the frick out of them.
Yeah!
No!
Wait, that lifeline just went crazy.
Yeah, their lifeline clutched it.
Yeah, gold knock.
Just tapping repeatedly.
Where's our gold knock?
Where the fuck is it?
Okay, I was 958 evo off.
I'm sorry.
No, we actually got fucked hard.
I'm not gonna lie.
Oh my god.
We had the zone, we had no beacon.
No beacon.
Like...
No!
We got no audio.
They can't place my money.
No!
It's okay.
These nades.
These nades might be it.
Somebody please throw more nades into them.
What is that team?
Take them out!
What is that team doing, bro?
Just kill this team.
Kill the lifeline!
How is the lifeline not dying?
Just kill!
Yeah!
She's doing her job.
She's playing back.
Wait, how?
Somebody please fire the lifeline.
That lifeline is actually going crazy.
Yeah, they're actually getting saved by the lifeline.
I can't believe it.
This team is the main character.
We're just the side characters.
Not fair.
Why can't we be the main character?
Wait!
Yes!
No!
No way!
They have fucking blood armor, bro.
Bro, no.
This team is the main character.
It's not fair.
What is this?
This is actually not fair.
The fact that all four of them are still alive after all that too.
Bro, this tournament is their stream, not our stream.
I feel like Naughty has been going kind of crazy these games.
Yeah, I know he has.
It's okay.
Guys, he deserves the money more than me.
It's okay, guys.
I have you guys.
I don't need...
He has eight kills.
It's okay.
We don't need the prize money.
It was just gonna go to tempo anyway.
He's going for the kill leader.
Oh yeah, the kill leader bonus.
Are you guys close to the kill leader bonus?
Hell no.
What the fuck?
It's okay, guys.
The prize money was gonna go to the tempo peak anyway.
We don't need it.
How are they not dead?
They are top three.
Bro, that lifeline is about to run at someone.
She's alive.
And she tapped!
Oh my god.
How are they living?
Someone at least kill one.
Bring one of them down!
Oh my god!
She gets the res again!
She died finally!
Jesus Christ!
Oh my god!
Wait, the Rampart!
The Rampart is living for free!
Oh my god!
How did she just do that with a 3x?
Did the Rampart win?
No, no, no.
She got second though.
Yeah.
The moment the Lifeline died, it was all over for this team.
Some crazy hating right there.
The more we hate, the more they succeed.
We need to...
increase our hate game.
No, the more we hate, the better they do!
No, no, no.
Because we're just not on the level of Kendrick Lamar yet.
You know?
We're not depressed enough to...
to vent out.
Wait a minute.
I'm sweating.
Oh my god.
Okay, LG guys, come on.
Guys, it's LG.
We gotta at least get top 6, guys.
That last game was unfortunate.
I would like some Boba money.
I don't know about y'all.
What kind of fucking Boba are you ordering?
Damn, $100 for Boba?
$100 for Boba?
You can get at least...
Are you living in LA?
Don't dox yourself.
Oh, you old...
You old and cis.
It's okay.
I live in...
like 30 to 45 minutes away from LA.
Oh, okay.
So it's not straight up LA LA.
Yeah.
That's better.
And you don't have to pay like, you know, $100 for Boba.
Yeah, only $50.
I can get like 10 Bobas.
Oh.
Big toppings.
Maybe like...
What's your Boba?
What's your order?
What is your Boba order?
I think the last time I got Boba, I tried this like watermelon coconut milk thing from Yifong Tea.
Oh, what?
That sounds fancy.
It was like a featured seasonal menu and I got that and I didn't like it and I was...
Oh.
I was like mad at myself.
I was like, why would I do that to myself?
That is actually like the Boba experience whenever you try to get a new one.
Yeah, the fancy one.
The plain ones are the classics.
There's a reason why they're the classics.
True.
Yeah.
You put too much stuff in it, the flavor will just get too mixed up.
There are too many contrasting textures.
It's not Boba, but it was matcha and peach.
Somehow it was good.
That sounds good.
Yeah, that sounds good.
It was actually really good.
Yeah.
What's your Boba order, Preez?
Uh...
I'm a basic b***h.
Milk tea?
Or brown sugar or Thai tea?
Oh.
Isn't Thai tea more sweet?
Yeah, I feel like you have a bit of a sweet tea.
Just for drinks.
That's it.
I don't eat any drinks.
Do you have at least Boba in your Boba tea?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I get the balls.
You know what now?
He gets the balls.
You get extra balls?
Yeah, the balls.
No, that's too many balls.
That's too much for me.
I can't take all that.
What am I eating?
Wait, what's your limit?
What's your ball limit?
You think I just count them?
I don't know.
Then how do you know when too many balls is too many if you don't have a limit?
I never thought about that.
I don't know.
That is a very good point.
Yeah.
Just ask for the balls.
I don't see how many.
Do you ask for it like that though or do you say like pearls or Boba?
Give me the balls.
Give me some balls please.
Oh my god.
What are the normal ones called?
Tapioca?
Yeah.
Boba.
They started adding all these crazy...
They started adding like the crazy ones.
There's popping Bobas.
Those are advanced.
Only the advanced Boba drinkers can deal the popping ones.
The advanced.
You gotta level up before you can take on the poppers.
I'm not that advanced.
Popping Boba with like a fruit tea is good though.
Mmm.
True.
I feel like that is a good combo.
There's also the tiny ones.
The tiny balls.
Oh.
Yeah.
There's tiny ones.
The really tiny ones.
Yeah.
That's scary to let you...
Wait.
In Boba?
Yeah.
You mix the big and the tiny ones together and the texture is really nice.
No.
You should try the texture.
I'm gonna try that next time.
Yeah.
The big and small balls.
I get the big and small balls.
Hey.
You got the small balls.
They're gonna tie to you with some small balls.
Oh.
And then there's like the...
There's like the jelly too.
There's jelly and there's pudding as well.
Oh.
I've had the jelly.
Jelly's good.
Yeah.
There's like different flavors for jelly.
I like the lychee jelly.
Oh.
The lychee jelly's good.
Now I wanna order Boba tea.
I wanna order me some L.A.
Boba tea.
Yeah.
I think if we win you can...
I can order my one Boba tea from L.A.
You can have L.A.
Boba shipped out to you at your hundred dollars.
That's true.
True.
And then it'll just arrive like a singular cup at your doorstep.
Guys.
Please.
I need that hundred dollars.
Or I'm not gonna get my Boba tea.
Wait.
You never said what you get.
Oh.
What I get?
I'm also simple.
I like the green milk tea.
And also...
And also like mango green milk tea.
It's really nice.
I love mango green milk tea.
Eww.
I don't like regular milk tea.
I like the green milk tea ones.
It just has more flavor.
Maybe.
Uh.
Guys.
What happened to Naughty's team?
What?
What's happening?
This is a team.
It's their lifeline.
No.
They just went into a team.
Yeah.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Wait.
They started it?
Say he's on the wrong team.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Guys.
Maybe we...
Maybe we cursed your IRL.
Wait.
She...
Yeah.
It didn't work in game.
We actually...
Her internet crashed.
Guys.
We're not liable for this.
We all have alibis.
Her internet crashed.
Oh no.
That's so sad.
Are we bad people?
Oh.
Fuck.
Get back.
No.
I never pretended to be a good person.
Fuck.
Oh no.
No.
It's okay.
She's back now.
Oh.
That's so good for her.
Dumb.
We like to see.
Fuck.
It's okay.
That means like if she crashed now.
That means she can crash again.
True.
So like there's hope for us.
Alright.
The team fused.
Long ass fucking tournament.
Yeah.
I'm tired.
I feel like we spent more time in the lobby.
But it just means that we have a...
More time to strategize.
Okay.
Yeah.
Bahankee.
Talk about fucking Milfman here.
I was gonna say hate but...
More time to hate on others.
Okay.
But realistically speaking.
What else have we done to strategize?
Outside of our comp.
I don't think anything...
We know what boba to order next time.
I don't know.
IGL?
IGL.
What were you supposed to do?
IGL?
Nah.
I was just listening to your guys' boba conversation.
You know.
I had a fun time.
I know what to order now.
You know?
Yeah.
But how are you gonna order boba tea?
We don't win anything.
We don't have some money.
I got third last game.
That's you problem.
You died first.
I got boba for one week.
For a week.
I'm fed for a week.
Okay.
But like...
What about the rest of us?
All I'm saying is Doki called us broke.
Yeah.
She said you broke us.
Fuck you.
Okay.
Yeah.
You're projecting.
I'm kidding.
Beacons.
Yay.
I wish I'm that broke fuck.
You should land there, Doki.
On your thing.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
We got everything.
I'll land here.
Can I double scan?
No.
And then you're just gonna get a gold res.
And she's gonna be her.
Nice.
Can you get a gold knockoff drop?
Can you get in like a bin?
Yeah.
You can.
You're gonna be her.
I believe.
Okay.
I'll try my best.
Land on the little pill there.
Yeah.
I just wanted to tag along.
I'm sorry.
No!
We had everything.
Our beacons.
We really had everything.
Dude, does Tembo hate you?
He hates all of us.
Oh my god.
If we don't get a beacon next game, I am accidentally crashing my game.
Accidentally.
I'm also gonna accidentally crash.
Holy shit.
How is this...
That's like actually so cruel.
Because we literally had everything.
And he just took it away from us.
We felt hope for like five seconds.
That's the...
That's the most happiness I felt in this tournament.
What was that?
What did they do to you?
What did they...
Are you okay?
Man.
I'm so sad.
That was the boba money.
That was it!
That was it right there!
I was already thinking about the small and big balls.
I was ready.
Where will my balls go now?
What the hell?
Oh my god, how could they?
I'm actually heartbroken.
We felt hope that maybe this game will be different.
He was there, man.
He was there.
I feel like I'm about to have nothing again.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
Maybe...
Maybe we'll get everything again.
Yeah.
Maybe.
Okay, who are we blaming?
Who fucked up here?
I don't know.
I think Tempo fucked up here.
Who fucked us over?
I think us actually preying on her downfall fucked us.
I think it was her that crashed again.
Was it actually her?
I'm pretty sure it was her again.
No, I don't think it was her.
Karma's not real.
There's no way.
Oh yeah, RainDay said it.
Yeah.
There's no way.
It's okay.
We'll get it again.
What if... what if we don't?
We will trust.
Don't put that energy out there.
If we don't get it again, should we just run into the first team we see?
Yes.
I actually am confident in our fighting ability.
I think, honestly speaking, we're not thinkers.
We should just uke uke one.
We should just grief a team.
And that's it.
That would make me feel a little bit of happiness.
What if we die?
You don't.
You don't think that.
Okay, you're right.
We'll be positive.
If we have the balls of a controller squad and just like eight them, they'll be caught off guard.
True.
And they'll give it for a little bit.
And that's all the advantage we need.
Oh, okay.
We got two.
Oh, we got three fucking bloopins.
Oh shit.
That's good.
The crash was good.
Okay.
We land on that bridge one.
I'm trying to fix my chat, guys.
I'm trying to fix you guys.
I'll fix you guys.
Okay.
Alright.
Who's jump master?
Okay, here we go.
I got it.
Solo jumping.
Bro, they really didn't put any ALGS rules.
I can Emo.
There's heat shields.
Am I going over there?
All the way over there?
Am I going there?
I don't know where you reset.
Yeah, you're going to spacebar.
Okay.
I just got to make sure.
Yup.
Alright.
Here we go.
Oh.
We got to make it.
I got three phoenixes.
Cool.
Hey, that's good.
Phoenixes are rare.
I don't want all of them.
The scout goes crazy.
Four phoenixes.
I don't want all of these.
Oh, shit.
Eh.
Alright.
This is it, guys.
I believe in us.
I believe.
Let's see.
I'm going to drop two of them by the crafter.
Alright.
Guys, this is it.
Bad zone.
Hey.
There's no way.
We're not going to get top six.
Can you ping me?
Yeah.
I have one here.
I'll ping it in a second.
Let's see.
I'm going to go...
Actually, I'm going to go nemesis.
I feel like nemesis.
I'm better at nemesis than carbide.
I'm pretty sure.
Okay.
Where's the bolt?
I need that.
Dropping an extra bat here.
Wait.
Scout or bolt?
I meant bat.
Did I say something else?
Scout.
Where is it?
I saw the bolt.
Where are the energy ammo?
Ping it in a second.
Does anyone want a turbo?
Uh, yeah.
Okay, there's a turbo somewhere here.
Let's go this way.
Bring it.
Oh yeah, I need to try and find it.
Guys, I have a panel after this.
I'm so fucking ready.
Core is leaving.
I feel like a balloon over here.
Be careful.
I'm so ready.
Do you have any...
Get that Evo there.
Yeah, I'm heading over now.
Nice.
Two bats in here.
Whoa.
Did you find a scout?
Yeah.
She's not gonna make it.
I'm drinking water right now.
Let's go to...
I can stand still here, right?
Where's he gonna be collecting cheese?
Hmm.
Okay.
Where's the turbo, guys?
It's kind of an awful hard zone if we don't get a spot right away.
Alright, I'm heading over.
We're gonna be fighting a lot.
I don't remember where the turbo is.
I'm sorry.
You guys can start heading towards Core.
Yeah, I'm heading over.
Alright, I'm okay.
I'm okay, guys!
I swear to God!
I'm okay now!
Should no one be here.
Should I get that cheese?
Yup.
We're gonna scan.
Okay.
I'm almost there.
Oh, damn.
I only have one bat.
That should stack.
I got two.
No one's playing from this side.
I don't think we're getting a house, guys.
Yeah, we should be able to scan from either that cliff base.
Or cliff side or alpha base.
I just fucking said two.
Yeah, there's a whole team in this house.
Alright.
We should try and...
I'mma hit that alone in the zone.
Okay.
So we're just waiting for you.
Or maybe we could go for the third beacon, too.
Me and a prize will go on a mission.
Yeah, you guys hold from this building.
Which building?
This thing over here.
I want a house so I can blow my nose!
I need a house!
I can't stop moving!
I need a house so I can blow my nose!
I think we should go for the alpha.
Please!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I need to blow my nose, please!
I feel like I heard something land that way.
I have a lot of notes.
I think those are the...
I did hear that, too.
That might have been the crafter.
I'm not sure.
I'm 200 off purple.
I can get cold now.
You can beat her!
You're gonna beat her!
We're gonna get her a red, too.
Guys, we got this.
The moment she has gold knocked down, it's over.
For them.
Not for us, by the way.
Just in case you guys don't know, it's over for them.
I'm gonna push her up here to see what this team is doing.
I'm gonna risk it.
Yeah, you're good.
They're on the other side.
We have purple!
Let's go!
Alright.
Where are we supposed to go here?
This building.
We're aiming for this building.
I think they're just...
I don't see them.
I'm gonna take the Evo cache.
Are you gonna take it?
I'll take it.
Send ult to Axel here.
I'm a little fridge!
Alright.
I have...
I need a stock.
Holy shit.
I have a stock.
I have one grey one.
They flew over from over here.
They left, okay.
Alright, start setting up there.
Or just chill here in this building.
We got scanned by cliffside.
Yeah.
I'm gonna zip us to the zones.
Or into the...
Beacons.
Put a wall for them and all that.
Okay.
Well...
We wait.
Alright.
Yay!
We got it.
She's over there too.
My team is so serious now.
This is the last game.
We gotta be serious.
We're so serious.
Is that a crafter or a mobile rose?
Probably the crafter.
I'm not sure.
Whoa.
I didn't even realize you guys were so far away.
Yeah.
Ooh.
There's two teams.
No one here.
Yeah, no one's playing.
Oh my god.
There's a team in...
We could play here.
Nah, I'm gonna die.
I forgot I dropped my syringe.
Can you res me, Yuji?
Yeah.
Um...
We have to make a position.
Oh wait.
I'm dumb.
There's no one in here.
Do you want a heat shield?
Yeah, no one's in that building.
We should definitely go for that.
I think we can land from this building.
We're good.
Yeah, let's go to this room.
I don't think there was anyone in any of... like both buildings.
Both buildings.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's go.
This team did look like they were looking though, so...
Alright, come on.
Wait, let's pop a med kit together.
Yeah.
Well, can you drop the suckage?
Huh?
Nothing, nothing.
It's okay.
I don't have a med kit.
Oh yeah, I can drop you now.
Alright, everyone pop a med kit.
Oh wait.
Can you bring it up here?
Oh.
Are you guys okay?
We have 20 seconds, guys.
We'll be fine.
Alright, pop a med kit.
We're gonna go for either of the buildings, but probably this one.
I'm so sorry.
I think I'm...
Yeah, you can drop the suck.
Oh, they're breaking the balloon.
We might just have to take it.
Oh, no.
Oh, wait.
Doki has a balloon.
I do, I do.
I do.
I dropped that balloon, Doki.
Someone else dropped it.
She actually dropped the balloon.
I dropped the balloon.
I don't trust my supposition in the balloon.
Take it, take it, take it.
What the fuck was that?
I'm gonna shoot for one of these.
I listened to orders.
Zip there now.
Go in here, go in here.
Fuck it.
Okay.
No one, no one, no one, no one.
There's a cheese outside.
We're gonna go for the next one as well.
We get to live in the house.
No one's here.
Okay, I'm closing this door.
Okay, guys.
I'm gonna AFK here for one second.
No, no, no.
We can't, we can't, Doki.
No!
I'm gonna blow my nose!
It's okay.
Later.
No!
We made it in!
I'm gonna blow my nose.
Run zone, run zone.
Oh my god.
It's a miracle.
I didn't even see that.
Holy shit.
Good call, good call.
Good call, guys!
We have a house!
And I blew my nose!
I want the sock.
Oh my god.
Gonna get the joe.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Back up, Doki, real quick.
Just out of our door!
Right here, Doki.
I'm a mess right now after blowing my nose.
Sorry, no, no, no.
No!
My Discord crashed!
What just happened?
Team right here now.
Guys, I'm a mess right now.
What is happening?
What fence is on this window as well?
Oh no.
Scary window.
We're gonna bounce forever.
Yeah.
You should not gonna bounce forever.
We moved together, you know?
Ape together strong.
Okay.
Just play together.
Are we shooting at it or on...
It's one problem after another.
Wait, there's a redeploy over there.
Alright, alright, alright.
We'll play Southwest.
I'm looking at them redeploying.
We're moving this, hold on.
Where are they going?
Where did they go?
They disappeared.
I don't know.
Yeah, I don't even see anything.
They actually just disappeared.
I was watching it.
There's a team over here.
Yup.
Why is no one here?
Me too.
Hello?
How do people know all these zones?
If no one's here, then do you think zone ends on the other side?
I mean, we have the zone knowledge.
Don't be a doomer.
Don't say that.
We don't have redeploy.
Oh, my bad.
We have our zip.
Oh yeah, we have our zip.
You're right.
They might valk back here.
Oh yeah.
I see that, yeah.
They just rez.
What the fuck are they doing?
It's a full team.
There's definitely a different team there.
I'm putting this wall back.
Alright, we're gonna find out in 14 seconds.
How is there still 14 squads?
There's literally only one team that has died this entire time.
That is crazy.
I'm a bit scared for you, man.
Don't worry.
I got this.
They're up here.
There's at least two or three teams.
Oh, I got shot from height.
Woah, woah, woah.
I'm looking out in the glass right now.
Speak of the reese, cause the doors are blocked.
Oh, there's a team right here!
There's a team in the other house next to us.
I'm gonna go in the other door.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They weren't here.
Open it real quick.
There's a team right here in front of me rotating right now.
Nah, I'm gonna move.
Holy shit!
Wait, can we get the thirst somehow?
I can't.
He's in this corner right here.
Yeah, we're trying.
I hit him for 100, his knockdown.
I don't have nades.
I'm gonna get him with this next one.
I'm gonna look on the other side just to be sure.
I'm going to...
I'm getting fired rifle!
Sorry, sorry.
Are you okay?
Yeah, I'm so sorry.
Oh, it's the reese.
I don't have an angle with you.
What?
We're not in zone.
Yeah, we're not in zone.
They were right.
I think they got a knock because they put down a mobi rez.
They put down a mobi rez.
I think the team is trying to move.
I think no one is in the first floor of this.
Yeah, I see it.
Come to me, come to me.
Fuck, that team is watching.
We gotta fight someone.
Stay here.
We're getting shot from here.
We have to get to the first floor of this building.
There's only one team.
This guy here cracked.
I knocked him, I knocked him.
Try to kill this team.
Okay.
Kill this team.
I don't know where this team is.
I got a shot right here.
Behind here.
On top, on top, on top.
I'm banging ult to them back.
I have ult here.
Oh, it's good.
I'm a waller.
I'm rezzing, I'm rezzing.
Go for the rez.
My ult didn't hit anybody.
You're good, you're good.
I'm batting.
We're gonna zip to the first floor of the building that's inside the zone.
Okay, wait, where are you?
I'm on wall, cool down.
This guy's gonna move.
That's pretty good.
You're gonna smoke the second floor and we're gonna zip in the first floor, okay?
Where's the second floor?
Right here.
Smoke that, smoke that, smoke that.
I'm gonna break the fence.
Go, go, go, go.
Just go first floor.
We made it, we made it, we made it, we made it.
Oh, we made it, we still made it, we still made it.
Watch the stairs, watch the stairs.
I'm watching the staircase, I'm watching the staircase.
Yep, yep, yep.
I'm locking this.
I'm watching this door.
Oh, they need it, they need it, they need it.
You're good, you're good.
I love it.
I'm batting.
Yeah, I'm covering you.
I'm watching our push.
I'm on max wall, cool down.
Okay, okay, okay.
Wait.
Oh, no.
There's a guy in the zone, never mind.
There's a guy in here.
Yeah, there's a guy like all the way over there.
Oh, wait, there's fucking stairs or a zone.
He can peek from this edge.
Oh, fuck bro, we're in a pretty bad spot.
Wait, right there is good, but fuck me.
What the fuck is going on?
Do you guys have vortex cups?
I do, I do, I do, I do.
Wait, wait, wait.
I think we can set up there now.
Where?
Right there.
You think so?
Oh, alright.
I don't know.
I don't think I've ever played there.
Fuck it, trust me.
Let's go guys.
We're going to save our cross.
I'm trusting, I'm trusting, I'm trusting.
Play in the crates.
Come here, come here.
We're building walls.
We're good, we're good, we're good.
I'm batting, I'm batting, I'm batting.
We're only going to focus our south east.
It's fine, it's fine.
I'm batting, I'm batting, I trust you.
I can't wall for you guys.
You're good, you're good, you're good.
It's fine, it's fine.
I'm going, look here.
In front of me, in front of me.
Oh shit.
I have to bat, I have to bat.
In front of me right here, in front of me right here.
There's a guy, he's in the open.
I see him, I see him.
Over here, by the ring.
He's still in the open.
I'm going to come put a wall for you guys.
He got his shields off, he got his shields off.
He died, he died.
I'm on cooldown.
Does your pack have a helmet?
There's a bat, there's bats in the package.
Come here, come here.
I'm dead, I'm dead.
You're good, you're good, you're good.
We live here, we live here.
Oh, nevermind.
That side is in, that side is in.
They're going to be chilling.
Come here.
I'm looking, I'm looking.
Be careful behind this.
We need a new wall here, we need a new wall here.
I'm on cooldown.
I'm third mining, I'm third mining.
One shot, one shot, one shot.
Nice.
Nice, nice, nice.
I'm not going to get the first.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
They're resing here.
Big, big, big, big.
Can these people top play?
Oh yeah, they can.
I'm still on cooldown on walls.
Okay, okay.
Right here.
I'm going to, I'm going to go out and kill this guy.
Rotate, rotate, rotate, in front of me!
Got him, got him, got him.
Flash, flash, flash, flash!
Right here, right here!
I knocked one, I knocked one.
Can you break the pylon?
That's a big thermite.
Okay, I need to heal, I need to heal.
They're dead, they're dead, they're dead, they're dead.
Oh no.
Noooo, your Zip!
Wait, come to me, wait, wait, wait.
Come back, come back.
You're talking bad.
You're talking bad, you're good.
You're good.
Stay there, Doki.
I'm staying!
Are they aiming?
Keep shielding.
No!
I'm so sorry.
There's a red right there!
We got top five!
I'm going for the red.
Yeah, go for it.
Go for it.
I just shoot him here.
It'll be so fucking cool.
It'll be a clip moment.
A clipable moment right there.
Watch for me.
Please.
Please!
We're getting Doki back.
This is for Bova.
Nice, nice, nice.
I cracked two.
It's for Bova!
Come back, Aprizi.
I'm back.
Wait, don't pick that.
Don't pick that.
You're not.
Just stay safe.
Think about the Bova!
Look at this.
This guy can climb.
Okay.
Fuck.
He got the balloon now.
Oh my god.
No.
I'm okay.
This is a bad spot.
Right here.
Full team.
Really fucking bad.
Really fucking bad spot.
Okay.
This guy to our left though can group us.
Yeah, lifehack, lifehack, lifehack.
Be careful of this team left.
Knock another one.
I don't know where they are.
I don't know where this left team went.
Right here.
Behind you.
This last team.
Wait, I might...
Wait, it is.
It is.
He's red.
He's red armor.
43.
Bangled.
Be careful.
He killed one.
Right here.
Nice.
No, no.
Up, down.
He is on top.
He's on high.
There is a fucking life line.
Get the fucking thirst.
Dropping, dropping, dropping.
I got the thirst.
They are pushing.
I'm pushing.
Under us.
Nice drone.
It's two.
Drop on him.
Nice.
LET'S GOOOOO!
Let's go!
Holy fucking shit!
We're down!
Let's fucking go!
Let's go!
Oh my god!
We're a fucking month I can't believe it!
We're a fucking month!
Oh my god!
That was crazy!
Good call on that zip!
Holy fuck!
That's fucking...
That's who we beat!
Naughty Steam!
We won!
Let's go!
Oh my second place!
Never first!
Naughty!
That's what I'm saying.
Let's go!
Oh my god!
That was crazy!
We hated 2-0!
See guys?
Kate wins!
Kill leader?
Oh my god!
Oh look at us!
We farmed!
Oh my god!
You gotta shit talk Wig!
Oh yeah!
True!
Bruce call him right now!
No you call him!
Alright, alright, alright.
Yeah!
Call him!
Oh my god!
We actually did it!
For the boba!
We actually!
We actually won for the boba!
Of course man!
Oh my god!
We actually did it!
Doki was talking mad shit about you bro!
What the fuck!
She was saying how bad you were cause she couldn't win with you but she wins with us!
Yeah I know that checked out!
Yeah I might have had one!
I told her to call you but she was like no you do it tell him what I said!
I was like damn that's crazy!
Tell him we won!
You guys never won together once?
No but I think that also just might be because we were laughing the whole time!
I don't know how the fuck we won bro!
I'm gonna be honest!
I have no idea how the fuck we won!
I don't know how the fuck we won!
Alright!
Love you man!
I love you so much!
Yeah bye bye!
Bro!
GG's!
I could have asked for a better last game team!
That was great!
Holy shit!
That was actually so fun!
That was fun!
I can't believe we did it guys!
Dude that res was crazy!
That was crazy!
Oh my god!
Oh shit!
Yuris you're like top 6 in kills!
I think!
You're top 6?
I think I got 4th!
Wait you had 15, Notti had 30 so you were not that close!
No but 1st and 4th gets money the same amount so hey!
Oh you got money?
I got money!
More boba!
He might have gotten 13th!
But I still got the same amount of money!
Damn!
GG's guys!
The power of boba and hate!
Yeah yeah!
If you really channel it in!
Yeah yeah yeah!
There was no karma!
Remember when we...
We're not bad people!
It's just how the world works!
That's crazy!
That's crazy to say!
You were just talking bad shit and you say we're not bad people!
If we're bad people we would have got punished!
That's crazy!
GG's guys!
That was fun!
I hope to see you guys again in the future!
Bye bye!
Oh my!
That was so fun!
I can't believe we won that game!
That was actually crazy!
I did not...
Bro the guy I shot died a ring!
Out of all chances!
I was like bro he died a ring?
I looked at it and I was like I got a knock and it was last ring and we won!
He died a fucking ring?
Holy shit!
That was actually fucking crazy!
That was so fun though!
That definitely was incredibly fun!
I'm glad...
It took me a while to get started socializing but um...
By the time we hit game 3 we were back in our groove!
I told you!
Apex is so fun when you have...
It's more so about who you play with and tournament stuff.
That's why I haven't been streaming much Apex because it's more about who I get to play with I think Apex is more about the banter and why you have some...
Sometimes you get sick gameplay footage too but the banter is so fun!
Um...
Guys!
We added more money to the tempo bank!
Yeah!
Another...
Another drop of tournament money in the tempo bank!
Um...
Alright let me go to...
Let me go to Yi-Ha time...
Oh shit!
Sorry guys!
We were...
Um...
We were talking about behind the scenes stuff but we're back now!
I'm gonna boost up the BGM a little bit while I was watching back...
But yeah!
I'm so happy!
I'm so happy with my team!
I hope you guys had a great time watching too because we haven't played Apex in a while.
Um...
Now time to cash out!
It's time to cash out guys!
Um...
But guys thank you all for the super chats!
I do have Avcon to go to I have Avcon to do now so I'm sorry I can't stay for too long but thank you all for all the super chats and all the memberships and all the...
gifted chips and subscribing or hanging out.
I really, really, really do appreciate it guys!
Um... That was a great Boba ad!
Boba Tea hire us!
Doesn't matter which company!
We literally just increased your Boba Tea sales by 100%!
Thank you for the super chat Burrito!
Thank you!
Um...
Bite size!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Nice win!
Now go forward your tax forms!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Anyway guys!
I'm gonna head off now!
As always everybody!
Stay hydrated!
Posture check!
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing!
And if you stayed up for me!
Head to bed!
Cause you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time everybody!
Bye guys!
Um... Bye!
By the way!
Um... Next week Um... It's not gonna be like super packed skit.
I don't know.
Maybe it will be.
I said I was gonna take a risk.
But next week we do have a stream with Mint playing Man of Medan. Um... She suggested it so Um... I think that's on...
Tuesday or Monday?
I think it's on...
Is it Monday or Tuesday?
I don't remember.
July 1st!
July 1st is Monday!
Is it July... Yeah!
Monday!
So...
Um... But yes!
I'll see you guys next time everybody!
Bye guys!
Bye!